Yeah. So guys, Wick did his Wick did his
big stream yesterday, okay? His big
fighting words stream, okay? Declaring
total reard war on the snarkers. All
right. And basically, he spends sort of
like the first I don't I going to the
estimations of time here cuz I I was in
and out watching it. He spends like an
hour, maybe two hours talking about like
he just describes common what would you
say like forms of jokes or sometimes
just like fallacies that you might
encounter online but describes them as
snarker tactics. Okay. So it's like
someone on Twitter will say something
wrong. They they'll either lie or
they'll be incorrect about drama. Some
no name on Twitter. And it's like that's
now that's now a snarker tactic. It's
now a snarker tactic. Like I saw Wick
posting I think it was Meera uh who's
who's a chatter and has a Twitter
account said something. It was just like
I think pretty sure it's just like
totally incorrect and he's like see this
is what they do. This this is what they
do. They lie. It's like yes Wick when
you're engaging with randoms on Twitter
sometimes they are incorrect or lying to
you. That does that does happen. That's
very true Wick. So he spends like an
hour and a half basically doing that. So
we go we'll take a look at some of that.
We'll go over some of the key points
here. I want to try and get most of the
the cliff notes.
>> Sweet KP Manny to the max. Yes sir. RZ
what the Sarah Buckley do not blink. I'm
sure Z Fox nice to you. Um Zer Fox you
might be one of I don't know if today
how's today's going to go moderation
wise right? But um I guess we'll find
out. We're going to find out together.
Me or because I get a lot of money from
having him on and all these things. Um
there's some truth like I I do I do get
benefits from the connection. That's
that's just true. But the problem is
with this narrative is that every
incentive actually in the space is to
ditch Destiny and this
>> such a lie
>> and what's happened to the people around
me I think is further evidence of that
right like the fact that I wasn't
willing to stop working with Destiny or
disown Dany or disow Destiny or anything
like that.
>> He he legit thinks that Connor is being
like unprincipled and bro or he's trying
to spin it that way. I truly don't know
if he believes it actually. It's just
crazy. I just don't know how anyone
feels that way.
>> Led to me getting doxed, bros. Right.
This This is their strategy. I I almost
I almost quit over all of this. I almost
quit over all this cuz I don't need this
in my life. I don't need this kind of
escalation. And since Wednesday, I
believe it was. It's escalated, gang.
Right. Um in every way you can think of,
um the harassment against me and the
people around me has increased 10fold
and it continues to increase and it will
continue to increase because that's the
incentive in the space. If you do not
dis disavow Destiny, if you do not
>> what harassment, what harassment
>> against Destiny? If you continue to work
with Destiny,
>> who is doing it? Point me to an instance
of something like doxing. It will be
banned every time.
>> Any way, shape, or form, they will hunt
you down. They will harass you. The
doxing is only one part of it, right?
I'm talking endless replies, endless
comments in chat.
>> So, now he's describing things that
aren't a problem. What What's the
problem with people replying to you on
Twitter? Sorry. No one's going around
policing people replying to you on
Twitter, Wick.
>> The replies, the Twitter replies, the
quote tweets, the quote tweets, the
replies. It's harassment. Okay. Okay,
dude. So, it's like at this point, they
sort of show their face. It's like you
just don't want people talking about
you. You hate the people being mean or
talking about you. I totally get it. If
there's an instance of doxing in some
community to be dealt with, absolutely.
anything that's like, you know, going
too far in that way. Anything that's
taking like into into real life
basically, which Doc Singh is the
gateway to. Yeah, that makes sense to
moderate. And people just talking [__]
to you on Twitter, bro. No one gives a
[__] Okay, no one gives a [__] Endless
paintings of whatever you do is evil and
wrong. And again, it took me a a bit to
realize this, but I've since realized it
since this the incident, right, that
they don't actually believe what they
mean. like none of their their
criticism. None of their comments, it's
all a strategy. None of it is honest.
And we're gonna talk about it. We're
gonna go through it. We're gonna
showcase what that looks like.
>> Okay. So, so he's gonna So, he's going
to give an example, something that I or
someone else have have pushed about him.
They don't believe. Now, hopefully this
is not just going to be some [__]
Twitter user and there's actually going
to be substantive. Let's see.
>> And talk about the tactics involved.
That's absolutely going to happen. But
again, I just want to address this first
like every social incentive, every
financial incentive, right? Hey, I do
make money from Destiny, but I would
make allowing him.
>> I would have more connections. I would
have more opportunity. All these things
would increase. Yes, I get a little from
Destiny, right? He doesn't pay me
directly obviously, but you know, I
benefit from the connection, but the
benefits I would have what other
opportunities he have
>> um is just with so much more. Even just
in the social circles, right? And this
is by design. This is the way that these
uh these groups, right, for lack of a
better term, um have set it up. It's a
tactic. It's an op. It's on purpose,
right? and they'll they'll paint you out
and and it's funny. Um
>> it's just it's literally it's so funny.
They're l just they're just literally
saying what they're doing. They are the
ones trying to say that basically ever
pitching your opinion on Twitter, ever
replying to [__] is bad and evil that
any collaboration between content
creators like coordination, the
associations are all toxic. That's what
you were doing.
>> Good analogy would be swift voting. I
don't know if you guys are uh old enough
to remember, but during the 2004
presidential
>> I've I've always been super clear about
where I draw lines on responsibility.
I've always said that just merely
associating with Destiny on its own is
not necessarily criticizable. I thought
I've reiterated these things many, many
times. Uh I don't think I've even said
that Wick is like a Destiny sweeper.
Isn't I'm pretty Am I crazy? Didn't he
read out a doobie donation right near
the start of a bunch of this asking if
Destiny had consent or some [__] like
that? Now, we might have criticized him
if he was breaking his own standards
around like doxing and stuff like this,
but that is a completely separate thing
to criticizing the association election.
Uh John Kerry was one of the candidates
and the Republicans developed a very
devious strategy to kind of uh to kind
of turn his strengths against him. So
John Ky was a veteran, right? He had a
Purple Heart, served in Vietnam. Um he
was a commander of of a group, right? Um
he had a lot going for it. That's that's
a great boon to have.
>> We have to speed through some of this.
>> But they figured out a way to turn that
against him and take a strength that he
had and turn it into weakness, right?
Through lies, deception,
mischaracterization, moving things
around. This is what the snuckers do,
right? They will paint a principled
stance and saying, "Hey, I look, I'm
getting attacked. I'm being harassed.
I'm getting docked. And all these people
are trying to push me uh to do something
that I do not believe, right? to do
something I don't want to do, to do
something that like I I just don't
believe that that's
>> who is trying to push you to do
something you don't believe.
>> As bad as everyone says. I just don't
believe that. I just if I did then I
would act different.
>> As bad as everyone says. What does that
mean, dude? This is what I hate, bro.
What do you mean as bad as everyone
says? What What do you believe and what
do you not believe? Just say that. Just
say that. Cuz plenty of people, I'm
sure, have views of Destiny that I think
go too far. I would say, "Wow, you
you're you are unhinged. You are a
little bit crazy about this." I'm I'm
sure that's the case. Sure, I'm not the
person who hates Destiny the most in the
world. But to say I think he's bad as
everyone says that is just that that
comes off like just downplaying that
because it's about what are you
contesting there? You should be specific
about what you're contesting and what
you believe. Do you believe he
non-conensually shared images and
videos? That's that's an that's an easy
one to to answer hopefully
>> but I just don't the evidence I find I
find very uncompelling and there's
contrary evidence that says Destiny's
kind of in some ways a stand up guy. I
don't
>> actual Hila Klein moment here.
Helilocline moment here. This thing's a
standup guy. Helila major Hila Klein
moment.
>> As bad as everyone says. I just don't
believe that. I just if I did then I
would act differently. But I just don't.
The evidence I find very uncompelling.
And there's contrary evidence that says
Destiny's kind of in some ways a stand
up guy. Look, I don't I don't like
everything he does.
>> But at the end of the day, he's one of
the only guys who's actually helped me
out. Who's actually been there for me
when I've needed something, right? Who's
actually
>> Oh, wow. Well, that's how you know he's
a standup guy. He helps Wick out
>> and he has no reason to do this. We
don't know each other. We're not [__]
friends.
>> Wick is Wick is always pathetic,
wretched, useless. So literally, why
would anyone ever help him out unless
they're like a saint?
>> We always kept a professional distance,
but he's been willing to.
>> So obviously your value is like a fake
neutral debate platform, right? That's
like obviously the value that Wick
provides. If he doesn't if he doesn't
realize that, he's kind of a [__]
mark.
>> Wick doing everything to be the deep to
destiny's homelander.
>> You were the $5. who you appreciate.
Thank you.
>> Be like, "Yeah, man. I'll help you out.
He doesn't get anything from me. Not
meaningfully. What are you talking
about? I get 50 to 100 viewers. If you
think that Destiny gets something from
me, you're [__] crazy. Okay, I don't
know what you're talking about." But
anyway, they take this this this um
principal stance I have where I was able
to stand up against the harassment,
stand up against all these people who've
been not just for the last week, but for
the last year or more, who've been
constantly constantly constantly pushing
>> a really principled stance where I stand
up to people being mean to me, but
people being mean to me. Those are the
people I'm against. Really principled
stance to separate from this guy. Okay.
Uh professionally, right? That's their
goal. that's their target, right? That's
that's what they wanted to do. Um, and
they've turned that into kind of like
this uh this this weakness, right? Like
this like unprincipled thing that I'm
only doing it for money. [__] that.
That's just not true. A lot of these
chatters just don't know what they're
talking about when it comes to how to
run a stream, how to make money from a
stream, how to um leverage connections,
how to build um a network. None of them.
They don't know. They haven't done it.
And when they've tried, they [__]
failed. You got people who have streams
and the most they've ever gotten is like
five to 10 viewers, okay? And and and
they they've since quit streaming
because they can't do it. They can't
make money out of it, right? And they're
trying to be like, well, you know, this
is what the incentives in the space look
like. They don't know. They have no
[__] clue, right? But they make these
lies up. Uh because again, and we're
going to talk about this more in more
detail, um they don't actually have to
have evidence. Evidence is something you
have to have. Evidence is something to
demand of you, right? This is not
something that they hold. This is not a
standard that they hold themselves to
ever, right? This is not a standard that
they themselves apply. It's a weapon.
It's a weapon that they use to attack
and to push their narrative. But we're
going to go through it. We're going to
get there. I'm already ranting. It's
going to be one of those shows, gang.
Okay? I got an outline and I'm trying to
follow it, but I'm already on my I'm
already waking out. Dang. I'm already
waking out. Okay? And look, I am on
edge. I have had a rough go of it. Um,
forgive me if I make mistakes during
this. Please forgive me if during this
whole thing I make mistakes. I'm going
to I'm going to make mistakes. This is
hard for me to navigate. It's personal
for me, but we're going to get there.
Let's get some super chats and we're
going to continue to talk about what
we're going to do. Um, because I think
it's important. My dollar mean sucks
what you're going through, but I'm glad
I don't have help. And what I think will
hurt them, and it really will, is point
out how they operate. And once you once
it's made known to you, you're going to
see it everywhere, man. You're going to
see it all over, right? Because they do
it most of it in the open, right? They
don't make a secret of it, right? And
you'll see the OP. And when you see it,
you'll be like, "Oh, a lot of things
will make sense, right? A lot of things
will make sense because they prey on
ignorance. They're like little roaches.
They hide in the dark." Okay.
>> Oh, listen. You sound mad to say, bro,
just take it easy,
>> right?
>> On what they do. Makes it harder for
them to do what they do. And we're going
to talk about it when we go through it.
Okay. Uh, thank you for the memberships,
EMA, and Duce Hilion or however you say
your name. I do appreciate it. So, at
the end of the day, $5
energy raised hand emoji.
>> Thank you. I got doxed, gang. Again,
this isn't the first time I've been
doxed, right? But the last time it
happened, it happened like as a group,
right? A bunch of us got all doxed at
the time. So, it felt a little it felt
different, right? It felt different. And
I knew it happened when it happened,
right? I knew that, okay, this happened,
but I can kind I could kind of hide
behind the larger creators a little bit,
right? And kind of keep it on the down
low and not really talk about it a
little bit and kind of slide through.
This time feels different. And and one
of the reasons is it's not just me that
got targeted, but it's it was Tally. I I
talked to those people, the people who
>> Okay, I don't know about anyone else,
but
>> age check on W.
>> Thank you for the $5. Uh, don't joke
about stuff like that. Stuff's hot right
now. Um, even though I'm sure he's part
of his age. Um, here's the thing, right?
The advice I've always heard, given,
followed, um, at least for the the
longest time. Don't uh confirm or deny
doxes. Generally, don't don't dress up.
But Wick Wick does like repeatedly
confirm [__] again and again and again
and again. I just don't I don't get it,
man. I don't get it.
>> Names I'm going to name. Um I talked to
them and got permission to say what I'm
going to say. Okay, we had a little
pow-wow. Okay, and uh we decided it is
better that people know and understand
just how this has gone. Um so Taly got
doxed, Stardust got doxed, and for Tally
specifically, uh they found her full
name. Uh they found the place where she
works, uh they found information on her
wife, they released her address of her
workplace, right? and they made it
explicitly known that they were looking
for her home address on uh Zillow for a
quote unquote complete docs, right? Um
and they've done this months ago, right?
I didn't know about it, but but it
happened. They want to keep us from
talking and the one of the biggest, I
guess, weapons that the Snarkers and
Snarker Jason communities have besides
anonymity, right? They they they we're
going to talk about one of the core
concepts we're going to talk about is
possible deniability and how they
operate in kind of like a cellular
structure.
>> Yeah. It's just it's just like he's like
some of the stuff he's mentioning is
literally like KF stuff. It's like
literally I don't know what anyone is
expected to do about [__] KF, but
he's grouping it all in. He's grouping
it all in as one thing because uh you're
criticizing me. Even though literally
there are people I've criticized for
years, nothing happened. Something
happens on KF and somehow it's not meant
to be my fault. It's crazy
>> and how they operate like a they have
crosspollinated communities where they
can uh easily disavow parts of it. They
don't have to give direct orders. Um but
they can still get what they want done
and we're going to talk about how that
works. Um, but one of the weapons that
they have besides that is fear. They
don't want you to talk about this. They
don't want you to discuss this. They
don't want this to be the topic of
conversation, right? Because they want
to make you afraid. So when you do speak
out about it, when you do start talking
about it, when you do learn about it and
you do like start speaking out against
them, the harassment levels against you,
especially if you're creator, are going
to increase. And I've seen that with me
specifically, it's just going to happen.
It's going to increase, right? And I had
to have a long think, right? Is this
something I want to deal with? Is this
something I want to deal with? And I to
be clear, I don't I don't want to deal
with this. If uh I had my way,
>> it is. It was destiny fit his definition
of internet terrorist that he applied to
carefuls yet. I wonder wouldn't be
talking about this at all. We'd be
political panels and all these things.
Um but it was happening to me and I
didn't even know it. I didn't even
realize it. It was happening to me and I
can't I don't want to let the terrorists
win. I'm going to be real with you. If
they thought that they could bully me
into silencer or make me afraid to speak
out, um you don't [__] know me, bro.
You don't [__] know me. I ain't
scared of you [__] Like I'm
going to fight you. We're going to have
a fight. Have you not watched my shows?
Do does Wick back down? Really? Is Wick
known for shutting up? Is that what
you've known for? Not really. One of the
biggest criticisms of my panels is I get
too involved. I get my fight. Not
really. So if you thought, oh, I'm
scared now. I'm going to go dark. Um,
nah. You miscalculated, [__]
We're going to get into it. $20. No
[__] way. [__] the haters, indeed.
Kim Jong the illst on Twitch. Thank you
for the prime sub. Really appreciate it.
Um, yeah. The environment around
streaming right now, especially in the
spaces I have, is the worst it's ever
been. The worst I've ever seen it. And
we've gone through some drama arcs.
We've gone through some some beef with
different creators. Um, it's never been
this.
>> Yes. And literally there is like one
side is saying any of this kind of
behavior will be moderated out. Nobody
has any tolerance for this kind of
behavior. It's moderated out. And
there's the other side going we love
doxing. We love doxing. We love doxing.
We love doxing. We love doxing. That
that's like literally what's happening.
And it's just pretending otherwise.
>> It's bad. It's never been this bad. A
lot of people are [__] on edge.
They're scared. They're scared because
it's all escalating. Like escalation is
just the name of the game now. It's all
kind of It feels like it's coming to a
head and I don't like it. I don't like
it at all and I don't I don't know how
to fix it other than to other than to
point it out, right? And to point out
how it's happening, why it's happening,
who's responsible, all these things,
right? Um and it's it may be that this
is the wrong move, but it's a move I'm
making. So, you know, here we go. Um I
do want to before we get into because
this happened uh this happened after I
made my outline, but I wanted to insert
it because it's worth talking about. Um
let's talk about counterpoints. You guys
remember counterpoints?
>> Wow. I think you should probably uh not
wick. I think whatever you've got to say
on this is going to be incredibly silly.
>> I don't got any beef with counterpoints.
I want to make that clear. I don't I
don't have ill will towards him or
anything. I don't know what he's going
through, man. Like, I have a lot of
sympathy for the guy, okay? He's he's
had a rough go of it. He's feeling the
same pressures I am. And I understand
that not everyone's going to respond to
these pressures different like the same.
They're all going to respond a little
differently. And on top of that, he's
got some real life [__] going on, right?
Um he's divorced, going through a
divorce, right? He
>> the crazy life changing [__] So, and
one of the things I want to stress is
you got to give you got to give some of
these creators grace, man. Um,
Counterpoint should not have done what
he did. Um, going out in public and
basically putting other people's
business on blast like that was very
inappropriate. And that's even dis
that's even disassociating it from it
from like the streamer dram.
>> So he literally he tried to confront
Destiny on this in November. It didn't
get better. This [__] is swirling
getting worse. And so he stepped up and
actually said something to him in
public. He did the absolute right thing.
>> The the friendship dynamics there,
right? putting out like other people's
sexual escapades and um dating statuses
on blast just because you're mad at a
friend and you want to hurt him with it.
All the while saying that you're doing
it as a tough love tactic. You're you're
turning other people's business into
like a a [__] weapon, man. Into a
bullet,
>> dude.
>> Highly inappropriate. That's just not
something you do.
>> Just keep keep letting your friends do
the same [__] up [__] again and again.
Why Why are you trying to stop it? You
don't you don't talk to friends like
that in public. Okay? Like this isn't
this isn't like this guy is so Mormon
something you do with a friend in
public. You if that had been a private
conversation that they had where he
wanted to be like man you're [__] up
your life cuz you're doing XYZ. You uh
you what are you doing man? Like fair
fair. I can see instances where that
would be entirely appropriate that where
it might even be the right thing to do
right. Um, and again, I don't I don't
know their entire dynamic, so please
keep that, you know, take it with a
grain of salt, right? I don't I don't
know their uh I don't know the truth
claims of what he was claiming, what he
wasn't, right? I don't know. Um, but
yeah, you don't do that [__] in public.
That's just not okay. That's just not
okay, man. How none of this is is real
in a real sense. None of it's all fake
and gay to to borrow a phrase. Um, these
are all astroturfed narratives that are
going around. These are all like they
make it look like it's organic and
people are just naturally feeling this
way but no they're not. These are
talking points that are manufactured
that are boosted that an organization
like like with organiz Okay, so this is
again just like villainizing literally
totally normal [__] It's actually fine
and good to make tweets and get your
friends to boost them. That's actually
fine and good. That's how you promote
yourself in content creation. Um, this
is literally he's trying to villainize
just tactics for growth. Yes, people
clip the the the most impactful,
important, scandalous cutting moments of
a stream and then they get their friends
to retweet it so it gets more attention.
Yep. The way it works. That's the game.
That's how the game's played. If you're
not doing that, you're falling behind.
And it's just that simple. Are clipping
and shipping and um all of this is is
astroturfed in a very real way. And
we're gonna get to that. Um, I want to
talk about who's at fault. This is one
of those things where I can't give you
solid answers because I don't know and I
want to make that clear what I'm saying
and what I'm not saying. I have
suspicions based on the evidence that I
have seen. There's a couple people who I
[__] know, but uh, you don't get to
know that information yet. Uh, but for
like other people, it's just suspicion
at this point. But I am fairly confident
that as more information comes out, some
of my suspicions will be will be
confirmed. But I just want to make sure
that everyone knows that I'm not making
any specific accusations against
specific people unless I say their
specific name. Okay? So, if you're
sitting there thinking, why is he
attacking me? Did I say your name? Then,
I mean, maybe if you're part of these
groups, uh, but I don't know if you're
part of these groups or not. Does that
make sense? We got it. We're on the same
page here. Cool. Okay. Uh, one of the
analogies that I think is important,
>> listen to this is what they're upset
about, guys. people being in anti anti-
Destiny discords discords where anti-
Destiny sentiment is rife. We need no
more crossover with any discords where
there there's ri anti-estiny sentiment
to kind of understand why I'm I have the
suspicions I do and I said this to Hutch
yesterday like a puzzle game. There are
some pieces that are of the puzzle that
are public that we all know that we all
can see and there are some pe uh puzzle
pieces that I've seen but you haven't.
Okay. And as the puzzle p as you get
more puzzle pieces, the picture becomes
more clear. And there comes a point when
you build a puzzle gang, when you're
putting together one of those 500 pieces
puzzles that you may not have all the
pieces in place. In fact, you may not
have a lot of these uh pieces in place,
but what the puzzle is representing,
what the the picture on the puzzle,
whether it be like a circus or a clown
or a city, it it becomes clear and you
know what the puzzle is building to. And
this is how intelligence gathering works
in the military when I was in there,
right? Um, it's why it was very
important that
>> W's military experience. Wakes military
experience. Let's hear it, man. Let's
[__] hear it.
>> It becomes clear and you know what the
puzzle is building to. And this is how
intelligence gathering works in the
military when I was in there, right? Um,
it's why it was very important not to
give even little bits to the enemy,
right? Not even to let them know a small
piece of insignificant information or
what you thought was insignificant
information.
>> [__] James Bond here, bro. Let's
[__] James Bond. Don't give any of
your intelligence, okay? If be very
careful with your intelligence, okay?
Give it a rest, man. Give it a [__]
rest.
>> Don't know what they know, okay? You
don't know what pieces of the puzzle
they've already put into place. And it's
very possible that your otherwise
inconsequential piece of information
that you think, well, how's this going
to help them? It's very possible that
that will be the piece that they need in
order to see the broad picture, right?
And to get a better understanding of
what's going on. So I don't need all the
information. I don't I need enough to
see the broader picture. And I think at
this point I have enough. And one of
those the biggest things that's changed
me from kind of I'm skeptical of all
these claims. I don't know. This seems a
lot. What are you like it felt like this
this feels a little this feels a little
conspiratorial, right? What are we doing
here? Um, one of the biggest pieces of
the puzzle that I've received is when
Destiny and Dan and Mutton and all those
people were saying, "Hey, this server
has has a docs in it. Has docses in it."
And the people
>> So, this is just again the same [__]
[__] man. Anyone that said definitively
without seeing literally every single
message in there, which you know, I
don't think anyone's seen every single
message in there, that there's no doxes
whatsoever, is obviously [__] Every
Discord server has some PII post at some
point. Measure of the server and the the
the culture. It's how it's handled. If
the person is banned, if it's dealt
with, if it's deleted, etc. That what
more can you do? What more can you do?
You cannot, you know, precog stop every
single Discord user whoever posts a
piece of PII. You cannot moderate things
you don't know about. All you all you
can do is deal with it appropriately
when it comes up and make sure you take
a firm sort like cultural line against
it.
>> We're uh on the Snark team and the Snark
side kept saying, "No, they don't. No,
you're lying. That's not true. We don't
dox people. We have no doxes in my in
our server." None of that's true. Um I
was shown evidence. Destiny was telling
the truth. And the people who were
telling me that the Snark server had
none of this in that we're lying. I am I
am a They want to use me as a weapon to
hurt Destiny, right? That's what they
want. Like it's not and that's so weird
to think about that it's not entirely
personal that I'm just I'm just here to
hurt another guy, right? They're just
wanting to hurt me so that this other
guy gets hurt. That's a weird it's a
weird feeling. Okay. It's very weird. I
don't know how to feel about it. I've
been struggling. Okay.
Um but then they then they do like not
only secondary people, right, but
tertiary people like targeting Tally
because she's next to me. What are you
What are you doing? What's going on?
What's happening? This is insane. This
is this is levels of crazy that I've
that boggle my mind. And I want to be
clear and I I hope I know I know I'm
leading with the doxing.
>> 50-year-old man stumbles on KF for the
first time. Totally horrified. Yep. Yep.
It can be it can be quite bad over
there. I don't
>> And that's obviously the catalyst of all
this. But I also want to make it clear
that that's that's not even the worst
part in a real way. It it is and it
isn't because you can only get docs
once, right? And the like once it's out
there, it's out there. Wait, then how
have you Wait, no, no, no, no, no, no.
If that's the case, Wick, then you
weren't doxed in that server, Wick. If
that's the case, then you weren't doxed
in that server. That's not how doxing
works. It doesn't matter if it's been
posted somewhere before. Each time it's
posted is an instance of doxing. So,
that was doxing, just to be totally
clear. But no, dude. What? I just
>> even the worst part in a real way. It it
is and it isn't because you can only get
docks once, right? And like once it's
out there, it's out there. Um kind of
TLDDR that it's it's just there. And
what are they going to do? Dox you
again, Dr. Moore. Okay, whatever. Um
>> yes. Yeah. Wick. Oh, dude. This is just
so Okay, I am recalibrate. I do not
think so. But I did take him repeatedly
confirming stuff as like an indication
that he didn't care and was weaponizing
it. Now I am realizing he just is like
so misled about like doxing and opsack
and anything like that. Jesus man.
>> The harassment just the constant
unending boomer about you. Just lies
just easily disprovable lies. That's
that's worse in my opinion in a in a
very real way because it's unending.
It's unrelenting and it it just no one
it doesn't stop and it really sucks. And
the people around me also get harassed
as a tertiary target, right? I'm I had
to tell my mod team like, "Bro, if you
need to distance yourself from me, it's
I understand. It's okay if you guys need
to
>> Okay, I'm just going to delete that
message just because you shouldn't point
people specifically
>> because I can't promise them that
they're not going to be a target."
>> Message message taken.
>> I can't. And that sucks. That sucks that
I have to tell.
>> Is anyone else feeling that big energy
raised back of hand emoji?
>> I got to say it's funnier the third
time. Jim, thank you for the $5.
>> Yeah, if it if it means that I can't get
guests. I don't know. Um, we're going to
have to think about it. Thank you for
the uh Wick TV gift membership. I do
appreciate that.
>> There you go. Literally, man. Oh my god.
>> I was going to say that's a little
dramatic maybe, but it's it's it's a
really happening. this is not something
I'm making up and I might be being um
dramatic about it, but these are the
thoughts I'm having and these are the
things that I'm worrying about and I
don't think my worries are unfounded
based on what I've seen, based what I
know. Uh it might work out. It might be
fine. People may be like, "Ah, it's the
internet. Uh that's always a risk." And
they may not care. Very possible.
Hopeful. I'm hopeful that's that's the
case, right? But this is this is a real
worry. This is a real stress on me. And
like one of the the things that that
Snarkers I'm not saying you're a snucker
just to be clear, right? I I just want
to
>> So Snarkers now encompasses KF as well.
This is just like crazy, man. It's just
like totally insane.
>> But that's one of the tactics, right,
that they're doing is they they
>> like how is this how are people not
totally ripping this apart? It's crazy
to me.
>> Stress you out, right? They want you to
worry. They want to minimize the things
that you're going through, right? They
minimize anything that they do to you
and anything you respond with will be
taken at maximum. Okay,
>> true. That is kind of in Destiny's
definition of snarkers.
>> That's just a tactic they use. But yeah,
uh $10 from Oh, 10 Canadian dollars.
Okay, so it's different. From Fancy T
says, "Snarkers have evolved the tactics
of Mr. Girl instead of co-opting DDG
subreddit. It's easier for them to go
satellite communities, dig themselves in
there, and then anywhere Destiny goes,
they are." Uh yeah, we're going to talk
about that. We're going to outline the
tactics that I've seen them used.
There's about there's about six layers
of delusional narrativizing packed into
that message. Mr. Girl was using
Destiny's Reddit against him because
what? He had arguments with Destiny on
stream and people agreed with him in
there. What What are we What the [__]
are we talking about? What the [__] are
you saying?
>> And that um I I I see them just working
with in the open, right?
>> Yeah. So,
a lot lot. Okay. There are three main
concepts that I think that we have to uh
we have to under well four main concepts
I should say that we have to understand.
>> Holy [__]
>> One of them the first I I I I want you
to understand so that you can understand
the tactics and understand the space and
understand how these works is how
legitimate actions can become
illegitimate in certain context. Okay.
How an action that would normally be
just fine. Nothing wrong with it. It's
just how it is. when paired with other
legitimate actions can turn into
something sinister. Uh an example,
driving in your car, just fine. We drive
to get every places. As long as you obey
the speed limit, who cares, right? Um
obey the rules of road, you're fine. But
when you have 10 cars all driving and
coordinating together to block a road
and slow down traffic, that's different.
each of the individual actions that
these people are doing perfectly
legitimate, but the coordination and
their goals and how they use the actions
becomes illegitimate. Does that make
sense? Another analogy. I got a few. I
wrote a couple down.
>> Wow.
>> Uh lighting a match. Okay. You light a
match uh to light your cigarette, uh
light a candle. Um if it's dark out and
you want to get some light, nothing
wrong with that, right? Perfectly
legitimate, perfectly fine. Nothing will
happen. But if you light a match next to
a gas leak, even though it's the same
action, because it's done in a different
environment, in a different context, you
have a different result. And the
snarkers have been pumping pumping gas
into every chat room, every voice call,
every comment section where normal
normal actions, normal things suddenly
have explosive results and they'll hide.
Literally, what what is the literally
I'm begging I I am begging Wick to make
an actual coherent point about what's
being done. Okay, cuz right now it just
sounds like he's talking about people
talking in Discord. Okay, so I'm I'm
waiting waiting. What is actually being
done with? Please go for it. The
legitimate portion, right? Or the the
legitimate thing. They they want you to
focus on the bricks so you can't see the
wall. Okay. And they'll hide behind that
and they that's a tactic that they'll
do, right? um that they'll say, "Well,
anyone can drive. I'm just driving, man.
There's nothing wrong with driving. Are
you trying to stop my right to drive? Of
course, I could just drive. I'm just a
American, right? I'm a citizen of the
internet. We could all just drive,
right?" But they're all doing it
together to block you, right? They're
all driving to block you in. Uh none
other says, "I think a better one, a
better analogy would be someone carrying
a weapon and shooting a mugger compared
to carrying a weapon to shoot a specific
person before you knew they were going
to mug someone." Well, there there's a
lot of analogies we can use. Those are
the ones I chose. Maybe there's better
ones, but those are the ones that I went
with. Okay. We're not going to be
perfect here today, but yes, they and
they'll mock it, too. Like, this guy's
just talking about this guy's just
talking about all we're doing is it's a
clip channel, bro. It's a clip channel.
That's all it is. That's all. It's just
a clip channel, which is fine in normal
context, but when it's coordinated,
targeted, edited, out of context, meant
to meant to target specific people for a
specific purpose. Uh meant to
>> So, show the example, wig, show the
example. Yes, anyone would agree.
coordinating to boost a false narrative
using out of context clips is wrong.
That's wrong. Anyone would agree. Any
reasonable person would agree. Now,
what's not wrong is coordinating to
boost clips where someone happens to be
criticizing you or where someone's
making a mean joke about you. That's
actually totally normal community
behavior because the thing that is wrong
there is not the boosting. It's not
anything like that. It's the lying. It's
the lying. It's the fact that someone
has lied and then obviously the rest of
it acts as a multiplier to that harm. So
it sort of takes on a new character in
some ways. But show that show that for
instance someone posted the clip of me
making jokes about Wick, but post it
with a [__] caption that said um
known child molester. It's [__]
State that's fact. I understand the
person posting it probably thinks oh
it's funny because the Mr. Girl
impression. [__] state that is fact.
So, I didn't like or retweet it. And I
when I saw it on stream, I said, "That's
[__] Why would you do that?"
>> Watch Mandalorian and Grou in theaters
now. Baby Yoda,
>> thank you for the $10, DOF. Huge
appreciated. Thank you. So, yeah, you
can point stuff like that. That's like
that's like someone doing that. That's
[__] and wrong. But then what's the
criticism? If you don't engage with it,
say it's bad, what more can be done
about a [__] tweet? The whole stream
is because he's mad about the leg
touching joke. That's how it comes off.
That's how it comes off.
>> And boosted and all these things, it can
become harassment. Even though clipping
is fine. There's nothing wrong with
clipping. But the coordination, the
context around it, why you're doing it,
to what purpose, to what end, can become
harassment. And it does have an effect
on people. And that effect is weaponized
against you, right? Because they'll
they'll they'll make you seem crazy.
They'll make you seem crazy. Like
>> literally literally 99% of cases
absolutely just not harassment. It's
just simply not the case. I'm sure you
can find examples like the one I
mentioned that'll say, "Yeah, but I
don't have I quite call it harassment."
It's kind of defamatory though. If I
quite call it harassment, but it's
certainly wrong. Um, but 99% of examples
aren't like that. You know, most of it
is people uh putting out their their
actual beliefs, what they actually
believe happened, the things they agree
with, the things they disagree with.
There's 99% of cases, and that's just
not harassment. You can cry about that
all you want. You can try and paint it
in a terrible way all you want. That's
never gonna stop.
>> Look at Wick. He's look at Wick ranting
um giving his psycho conspiratorial
opinion, right? I saw these clips
already put out with my talk with Hutch,
right? Where I kind of outlined a little
bit of this. Um it's an op game. These
people are coordinated
communities like [__] KF to everyone
else, [__] You're just drawing a
bunch of associations to like attack
people that you literally can't
substantiate when literally it's I know
I don't [__] around with that [__] so I
know it's not the case yet. But wick is
deliberately tying me to it.
>> Changes it. That changes the nature of
what is being done. I want you guys to
understand that. It absolutely does. Um
so yeah, that's the concept that I think
you need to understand the first two how
legitimate actions can become
illegitimate in different contexts and
how coordination matters. They want
every step judged in isolation because
each step
>> we will end. Very true. Very true.
>> But harassment campaigns are not built
out of one giant indefensible act. They
are built out of many small defensible
acts arranged towards an indefensible
purpose. Example, a streamer makes a
messy comment during a three-hour
broadcast. The indefensible purpose
being crit criticizing Destiny.
Criticizing Destiny in Israel. Hating
Destiny. Like they said, hating Destiny,
hating Ethan Klein, and hating Israel.
Just an indefensible purpose. How could
anyone ever feel that way?
>> A hostile viewer clips 15 seconds of it.
That viewer posts it in a server
dedicated to attacking that streamer.
The server agrees uh the server like
they they do like their they manufacture
talking points, agrees on the harshest
possible interpretation. The members of
that server begin posting the clip with
similar captions, uh similar hashtags,
all these things. Members begin um
sending it out to other streamers that
may or not may not be connected to this,
right? I I do want to get into another
core concept later. The and another
tactic they use the plausible
deniability, the they use unrelated
actors to further their goals as part of
the machine even though these other
unrelated actors do not realize that
they are part of the machine, right? um
the they go in and they react to it into
the context of it as if it's already
settled, right? Like this is obviously
what it means. Um there is no other
interpretation. If you have another
interpretation, you're stupid, etc. And
then people will go in and send people
into these chats of streamers reacting
to it.
>> So again, this is literally how is this
any different? How is this not just
trying to get your content covered by
other people? Yes, I will go to Becket
and I'll say, "Becky, you should cover
this. Becky, you should cover this. I
demand what he thinks though. We if he
disagrees with me, we'll argue about it.
But again, what's the wrong part here?
What is being done wrong here? No one
has to agree. No one has to cover it.
But absolutely, you should try and get
your stuff covered. You should try and
get your clips out there. Those things
you should do as a content creator and
those are things they have an issue
with.
>> Maybe not be part of the machine or the
streamers themselves that they're
clipping to stir [__]
>> You're you're expressing my your
opinions and they're against me. Why are
you doing that? Why are you doing that?
Okay, man. We'll we'll stop that
immediately. Actually, we'll stop that
right now.
>> Right. to get react.
>> You're making mean but funny jokes about
me. You're saying it would be traumatic
for any woman to have their leg touched
by me. That's harassment.
That's harassment. Stop doing that. No
wig. No wig. It's not happening. Wig
>> actions for more clips to uh spread it
even around anymore to kind of create
this this narrative that they can use to
serve their purpose. And
>> did you really spend an hour on stream
talking about the way I eat? Huh? Did
you reach for You're obsessed. You're
crazy. You're harassing me.
>> All of And all of these acts by
themselves might be defensible in
different contexts, right? Well, there's
nothing wrong with clipping people.
There's nothing wrong with giving your
opinion. There's nothing wrong with
reacting some yummy take like Wick
sucks. Wick handled that bad, right?
There's nothing wrong about boosting
your friends. Like if your friends wants
you to boost their clip, nothing wrong
with that in isolation, right? But it's
the coordination. Uh and they'll start
tagging the streamer's guests. They'll
start uh sending it to the streamer
sponsors and say, "Is this your boy?
Look at what your boy said about Israel
Palestine." You gonna you gonna let him
say that? Right. And when the streamer
gets angry or defensive,
>> the Okay. Yeah. Most people around here
disagree with like the sponsor targeting
tactics. So, I don't even know what this
is about. This is like literally now now
we're building in like just like
snarkers are also all um is also all pro
pressure campaigns as well because
they'll see it happening. that's clipped
too and it's used to push right the
narrative stress the target out so that
they make mistakes and it's a whole
system okay and remember this is the
goal of the snark server they have
target it's not just Destiny by the way
uh Ethan Klein uh few others they've
targeted Hutch they've targeted Lonerbox
I believe um I I don't know the full
target list I don't have access to the
logs right but they have targets and
they are targeting them they targeted me
right that's that's how what's
happening, right? And again, they'll
retreat to the they'll want every aspect
judged in isolation. And they'll retreat
to that. And they'll be like, "Bro,
we're just clipping. What's wrong with
clipping because it hides and obuscates
the scale of what they're doing and the
real purpose of what they're doing,
which is to harass and JTO?" And yes,
I'm naming names.
>> Dude, nobody g Okay, literally no
content creator gives a [__] about
harassing you. There might be some
[__] chatters that do stupid [__]
that be that you know gets moderated if
it breaks the rules of the platform, but
no content creator has a [__]
interest in harassing you, Wick. It's so
[__] [__] Content creators are
driven by money and clout. That's pretty
it's a pretty universal rule. Money,
clout, and some extent usually respect
as well. You know, those are like the
things that drive most content creators.
I know for a fact I care about first of
well you know I care about my career not
so much that I would you know I mean
you've watched me do it you watched me
just like totally rape my connection to
Dioro and uh and uh get get made a
pariah for being right about Ethan too
early. Um so you know I I say I'm I I
want to say I'm like super career
motivated but then I will totally just
do [__] [__] But, you know, for the
most part, I'm I'm here to make money.
You know, for the most part, here to
make money. So, no one's got a [__]
interest in wasting their time harassing
Wick. Okay? No one's got an interest in
that. It's just it's really funny to
make fun of you eating. And you're a
very embarrassing, very pro-Israel guy,
so you're a good sort of like content
piece. Do you know what I mean? In the
same way that a Froggen is a good, you
know, content source. Wick is a good
content source. You know what I mean?
Hopefully that makes sense. has called
for the mass reporting of different
targets and he has used this system of
harassment and coordination to create
the justification
which is to harass and JTOK and yes I'm
naming names has called for the mass
reporting of different targets and of
different targets or just of Destiny
because Destiny was on an active doxing
campaign where he explicitly stated he
was going to dox the most active members
of JO's community in order to kill his
community. He has used this system of
harassment and coordination to create
the justification where he can call for
that where he makes others feel
justified in taking that action. I can't
give you the details of every single
thing that he's done to do this but he
has admitted to ma to calling for the
mass reporting of people. And you have
to remember right that this is the goal,
okay? The goal isn't to get to the
truth. They aren't mass reporting
because they've done something right
because they've organically done
something wrong. They're mass reporting
because they hate them, right? They hate
them. So, they're building a permission
structure. They're building up a
justification to say why what they are
doing against the people that they hate
is righteous and just. It's a
coordination campaign. It's what it is.
It's astroturf. It's like um it's like
Trump sending out uh to all the people
in uh the group chats on MAGA side um
after his like third assassination
attempt that they we have to build the
ballroom. Okay. They want it to feel
organic, but it's not. It's astroturfed.
It's not organic at all. Okay. Thank you
for the fourmonth RZ what the [__]
membership reminder folks to smash that
like button. Yeah, give me money, gang.
That's all nice, right? And remember, a
lot of each each of the people
individuals in this this server, not all
of them share the same level of guilt.
And I want to make that clear, right?
>> Is we're going to I wish they would
literally just engage with J's reason on
the reporting [__] but they just they
refuse to because it's like how do you
fight it? What's the counter argument?
Best thing explicitly states he wants to
kill Jox community with an active doxing
campaign against the most active
members. What else can he do? Yeah. When
when else do you report someone,
>> right? Um if you're just in the server,
who the [__] cares? I don't. But if
you've been part of this coordination,
if you've been involved to certain
degrees, the more involved you are, the
more culpability I feel that you have.
Okay. Are you one of the people who are
going into other people's uh [__]
chat rooms during [__] Are you one of
the people hiding, pretending to be
someone else or pretending to be a DJer
or pretending to be uh from a different
community just to start [__] just to
get people to react so that they can
feed it into this machine that they've
created? Um well, then you share a
little more culpability. If you're one
of the people who posted my [__] docs
or laughed at it.
>> Oh, wait. Chat chat is doing [__]
[__] There's no way, bro. No way. Chats
are doing [__] [__] dude. Holy
[__] It's over.
>> To fight it and then you share a lot of
cappa building. Okay,
>> that justifies a bunch of doxing
actually. I think if there's some
chatters doing some like [__] [__]
[__] starring between different chats. I
think uh doxing is on the table.
Actually, this makes a lot of sense.
Wick. This sounds like a very moral
principled position that creates a very
healthy environment. This totally isn't
motivated by personal grievance. I don't
know the levels at to which every single
person in there is culpable. I just
don't. But I'm telling you what they're
doing. I'm telling you how they're doing
it. And again, I don't have all the
pieces of the puzzle. I might get a
detail wrong here or two, but this is
what we see happening. $5. No [__]
way. Says, "What makes a great movie?"
Great actors. And yeah, this is
gangstalking. Felony level cyber crimes.
Well, I I don't know what gangstalking
is, so I can't say whether it's
gangstalking or not. I don't know, dude.
It's so crazy how these people hype each
other up. You see this on the H3
subreddit as well, man. It's
gangstalking, felony level cyber crimes.
You've lost your [__] mind. Oh. Uh,
Philanth Mike says, "Okay, Wick, I know
you've never I've never spoken here
before, but here's a counter point for
you. Have you thought about the fact
that Destiny is a girl's name?" Fair
enough. True. Women, am I right, gang?
Huh? Women
>> consequences.
>> Oh, thank you for uh thank you for the
example. Uh Greg Zik,
if there are levels to it, what level of
culpable are you are you for Destiny and
DGD doxing? So, I guess we're going to
we have a couple more core points to get
to, but this is a good example of one of
the major main tactics that snuckers
use. Always, always, always be on
offense. If someone is talking about
what you're doing, what about Destiny?
And and people are going to react to
this and this is this is what they will
say, right? the I will make an
accusation. I will
>> I've I've literally I've literally
directly addressed every single point
he's made as far as I'm aware. Maybe
maybe I missed something. I was grabbing
a drink or something. I have directly
addressed every point he's made. The
only thing where you could even argue of
what about Destiny is the JTO reporting
thing. That is only because he is taking
the JTO report out of the context of
what he's reporting for. So just not
just to total [__] here.
speak about what they're doing and the
wrongs the uh the wrongs that they are
doing the the bad things that they're
doing and wait for it and you'll hear
it. What about Destiny? What about DG?
What about all these other people? What
about everything else? And it's a way to
always always always be on offense
because they want you litigating. And
Connor counterpoints did this. I don't
know if he did this on purpose or just
he was just
>> Now, however, Wick, now that you mention
it, there is obviously a point here that
it's not a real standard. None of the
standards DJ pretend to care about are
actually standards they hold because any
instance you can find of something going
too far will be actioned on this side.
It has never not been the case and will
not be the case on the other side. And
it's just that simple. Just that simple.
And they keep trying to do this thing
where it's like, oh, at least Destiny
Destiny and Dan own their [__] yet. What
is there to own? I'm not going to own
things I don't do. It's just so obvious
the attempt is just to drag everyone
down into the same mod. It's just to
flood the zone. drag everyone down into
the same mud. Act like there's just no
difference. No, actually, not all not
every single man ever uh has shared
non-conentual nude imagery. That's not
true. Actually, that's false. Actually,
Stardust, that's not correct. [__]
mind raped, as Destiny likes to say. Um,
instead of talking about what the
snarkers were doing, he wanted to
litigate Destiny's sex life. What does
that have anything to [__] do with
what we are talking? Nothing. But
>> he's [__]
>> People feel the need to defend
themselves. People feel the need to be
like answer to explain. But if you're
excusing
>> this thing has a very public messy sex
life. When you're a celebrity or pseudo
celebrity, that's going to be in the in
the quote unquote news. I don't overrate
myself too much here in the quote
unquote news. You know, that's the point
Connor is making. That's the source of
his problems.
>> You're losing in the rhetoric war,
right? So that's the first tactic.
Always, always, always, always, always,
always, always attack. Never, ever,
ever, ever make the conversation about
what's happening on the doxing server or
the Snark server or with JTOK or with
all these other people. Always, always,
always, always make the conversation,
what about Destiny? What is Destiny
doing? What is DGD doing? That's the
first and most important tactic that I
need you guys to understand. I need you
to understand it. And this isn't a
conspiracy. You can see it. It's
happening in my chat right the [__] now.
Right. It's happening on Twitter every
single every single day.
just what there's a valid point in there
which is that they don't hold the
standards. They don't and haven't held
the standards. We've maintained the
standards or at least I have. I won't
speak for everyone, you know, that's
always stupid. I've maintained the
standards the whole time though. Don't
dox. Don't dox. Don't lie. Jokes are
epic. Very few very very very few jokes
are too far. You know, those are my
standards. I I'm very clear every single
time it's what about Destiny? What about
Destiny? What about Destiny? What about
DG? Always, always, always, always
attack because if you're excusing,
you're losing. If you're explaining,
it's lame, right? You are losing the
conversation if you're explaining.
>> That's four. Let's go.
>> Is anyone else feeling that big wick
energy?
>> That's huge.
>> Raised hand emoji.
>> Big wick energy coming through.
>> It's a like whatever sins you may or may
not,
>> yep,
>> have committed or may may not be uh
guilty of. So, just recognize that. And
remember, these people aren't in
earnest. They're not genuine um nine
times out of 10. They hide amongst
people who are and this is what's
important. Just because have someone has
a problem with what Destiny has done
does not make them a snucker. Okay,
we're going to talk about that later.
I'm getting I'm getting ahead of myself.
I'm getting ahead of myself. The one
triggered me a little bit, but I wanted
to make that clear. Okay, sorry. Let's
back up. Read some super chat. $5 says,
"What is Destiny doing uh right now?
Wick, you're streaming, but what is
Destiny doing?" Oh, that's a good
question. I have no [__] clue. Uh $5
from the Witches Persona says, "Licass
Darvo, the same as manga, just replace
Destiny with Biden." True
true. Okay. Uh, let's see. There's a
couple more core points that I need you
to understand. Oh, yes. Um, how they
operate in the realm of plausible
deniability where they can keep their
hands clean while still getting the
results that they want. A good example,
um, you may not specifically direct
every raindrop or lightning strike, but
if you've seeded the storm, you were
still responsible.
>> Seed seeding the storm meaning
criticizing other people's takes. That's
what's being referred to here, guys.
Because that's what they use this
analogy for on Twitter. They said, "I
was responsible for getting Stardust
getting doxed." Why, guys? Because I
criticized her and someone clipped
something she said and that got spread
around and then someone on KF posted
that and doxed her. That's that's why.
Okay. So, that that is now my fault.
Even though I covered her for 4 years
and nothing like that happened, the
moment that does happen, it's my fault.
And I wouldn't usually be that, you
know, I I don't want to talk about where
where stuff is or anything like that. I
[__] hate bringing attention to it.
But they keep leveling the accusation at
me. How can I talk about it without, you
know, bringing stuff up? It's crazy what
happens to a certain extent. There are
levels to this. There's some nuance
here. Are you as responsible as the
person who pulled the trigger? No,
obviously not. Do you bear some
responsibility? Yeah, kind of. So, I
guess when judging these things, there's
kind of like a checklist when because
because if you're looking for the
standard of evidence of do you have a DM
of where JTOK or any of these people,
uh, DM them to Doc Wick or DM someone to
Doc Tally or DM someone?
>> These people getting doxed benefits me
[__] zero. In fact, if it hurts me to
be honest, these people benefit, it
benefits me [__] zero to see these
people getting doxed. Literally no
benefit to me whatsoever. the the idea
that I want that to happen, the idea I'm
encouraging that, it's not only not
substantiated, it just doesn't make any
sense
>> to harass this person or that person or
the other person. Um, nine times out of
10, you're not going to have that.
That's just it's not necessary. They
don't have to say that directly, right?
Why? Like, why would they? Obviously,
Chase has said about the mass reporting
thing directly, which was really dumb of
him, but these people aren't the
brightest. They're bright enough. Like,
there's some cleverness here.
>> Contest the reasoning. Contest the
reasoning. I want to see I want to hear
Wick explain it. Destiny stated
explicitly he was going to dox the most
active members of Jour's community on a
doxing spree che and through the doctors
and he was doing it. He was doing it.
How else does he handle that? What's his
other recourse?
>> Some kind of understanding of human
nature to kind of set up something like
this. But yeah, that that's so silly. Um
so you get there's a checklist for me
that I kind of go through, okay, that I
want to kind of go through. And you
don't have to hit all these points to
bear responsibility. Uh but if you hit
enough of them, I think there's some
responsibility that you have to kind of
uh accept. Um so the real question is
when something like this happens, like
you got to ask yourself who named the
targets, who framed them as deserving,
who supplied the narrative that it was
permissible, right? Who created the
permission structure for this, right?
Who just who justified doing this? Like
it would be okay to do this because of
XYZ, right? Um who boasted the
attackers? Uh who rewarded the
escalation? So, like for example, if um
someone on Kiwi Farms goes after and
doxes someone and then you have people
in a community, cheer that person on and
give them accolades, give them flowers.
There's some culpability.
>> Is this the crying about the Blav W [__]
again? Yeah. You know the culpies on
there? It's on [__] Destiny for
making this guy a [__] character in
stream. [__]
>> be there.
>> Nobody's cheering him on doxing people.
>> Who laughed when lines are crossed? Who
found it funny? who was amused that
their enemy got hurt, right? Who
protected the people involved, who run
cover for it, right? Who minimized it
afterward? Who's talked about like, you
know, Wick, I know you got docked, but
it really wasn't that bad, man. Like,
you're still fine. It's no good. Like,
look, uh, other people have had worse.
This is not who minimized it, right? And
I think one of the most important
questions is who benefited from it. So,
when you ask yourself like what level of
culpability do people have? I think
these are some good basic questions to
start to ask. It's a good checklist to
kind of go over. And remember, not a
single one of these things requires an
individual person to direct another
individual person to do an act, right?
And that's how they thrive. And it's why
it's really really hard to kind of uh
unless you unless you happen to have a
bunch of logs that they didn't know you
were logging, um it's really really hard
to kind of point out specific bad actors
in this, right? They all hide in this
this like uh this plausible.
>> No, it's actually really easy because if
someone's lying or if someone's doxing,
you point to where they do it and then
and it can be handled, right? In
whatever appropriate way that should be
handled, whether it's stating the
correct information or it's stuff like
doxing and banning people. It's it's
actually really quite easy, I think, to
identify bad actors.
>> Deniability space, right? So, like I'll
give you I'll give you an analogy. You
have a factory owner who's who's built a
machine, okay, or who's helped to build
a machine, they may not personally
operate the machine, but if he designed
the factory, if he ignored the safety
warnings, if he rewarded speed over
caution, if he punished people who
complained about it, he bears
responsibility when the machine
eventually hurts someone. And I'm not
claiming that every central figure in
all this personally did every bad act.
That would be an absurd standard, okay?
That that that we would never meet that
standard, right? Like Trump didn't
personally go in and break in on January
6th, but he still bears responsibility.
>> You know, I don't contest, Wick. It's
really funny jokes that might paint you
in a bad light. And that's what we're
really upset about here, isn't it?
That's what we're really upset about.
Meanwhile, DJ is doing like the absolute
most insane [__] you've ever seen. Just
obligatory. Getting that in there. This
is what Wick's upset about, guys. This
is what he's really mad about. Let's
see. This is the ring leading of
harassment I've done against Wick.
>> Here is Queman. He did a little I don't
know why he posted me in response to
what Disney tweeted, but this is me as a
pretty kitty. Okay, I'm a pretty kitty
wick. First off,
>> a pretty side.
>> Um I don't know why you guys think
you're going to embarrass me for posting
things that I posted publicly. Like if I
was embarrassed about this, I wouldn't
have done it. I don't know. I don't know
what you think you're going to do here.
Like, yes, I dressed up as a kitty for
Chaos Cast. It was funny. I was a great
actor. Okay. Okay, I was a very pretty
kitty. This doesn't embarrass me. But
there's something like I don't mind.
Like if you're going to like post me
eating ramen noodles or dancing or
whatever, whatever. I don't give a [__]
It's sometimes annoying depending, but
>> Oh, it's annoying. Oh. Oh, but he
doesn't care. Sometimes annoying, but he
doesn't care, guys. That's why he's
going red in the face to explain the the
pretty kitty clip. He's he's he's
unbothered in his element. But that's
not all they do. Um, let me show you
something. This was from a couple years
ago that Queman did. Um, that
demonstrates this. And the joke and and
and remember the defense for this has
always been it's just a joke. Wick. It's
just a joke, right? But they only make
that defense.
>> Guys, tone indicator J guys incoming.
>> Like when I call it out. when I'm not
calling it out. You're talking to people
in DMs. They're going around and
spreading the rumor that this has
actually happened. So, let me just read
the tweet and we'll watch the clip. So,
uh this is me replying classroom.
>> Say, "Hey,
>> who would you go? I didn't want to make
the joke. This guy's going to cry if I
even joke. This guy's l going to cry so
hard if I even make the joke." People in
the classroom going, "I don't believe
this guys/j
I don't believe a I'm about to make."
People going around the class going a
pedophile. Pass it on. Mix a pedophile.
Mix a pedophile. Pass on slashj guys.
Slash Jay. Haha. Because he's not really
a pedophile, guys. He just looks like a
pedophile. Here's your audience painting
me out as someone who engaged in sexual
assault against a woman. Lying to your
audience despite that same woman later
making it clear to folks that this was
absolutely not the case. And not just
later, she was doing it at the time,
too. Right. He's going to show one part
of a chat, but he won't show the rest.
We're going to get to that. Um, and then
when he's called out on it, he retreats
to just jokes. Note that this just one
part of an active campaign to slander me
and paint me down to be a second because
this isn't all they've done. This isn't
all Quimman has said on this. And he
said stuff recently, too, on his stream
about me and Kinetic Kell, right? That's
what he's done. Um, he's a liar and a
fraud. And worst of all, he's [__]
British, so I don't know what the [__]
he's doing trying to make fun of me.
He's
>> British. British. British, [__]
>> Please schools.
>> Let's bring up
>> There's actually some terrible.
>> Yeah, let's let's watch the clip. We'll
just watch the clip and you can
>> go to you.
>> What you think, dear viewer?
>> There's actually some terrible terrible
allegations. Absolutely horrific stuff,
I got to say, that's been brought up
about
>> Tuesday. Tuesday,
>> last day of water. So, bug squander has
been pressing for information at Ginger
Ramoth. Did Wick ask for consent prior
to groping yourself and Madame Genevieve
in that photo that was posted? And as
you can see here, if we get some zoom
and enhance analysis going on, you can
see here Wick is touching it appears to
be Madam Genevie
>> touching people's legs that you're at a
party with and you're friends with.
Crazy. But here's how they paint it.
>> Outer thigh and knee. And yeah, this is
this is the outer thigh here as well.
The outer thigh and the on Ginger
Ramoth. Who? Ramoff. What? Ramoff.
Now, obviously, we've got the response
here. He did not He did not ask. He did
not say, "Man, would you mind if I
touched your leg before?"
>> Who does that with friends? First of
all,
>> it's so good, man. You can't make it up.
>> But you see how they're painting it
right? You see how they're clipping
Ginger Ramoth and what she said and
we're gonna we're gonna go to what else
she said and we're going to talk about
how this
>> So you're admitting you didn't ask
consent. So is that an admission that
you didn't ask consent before touching
your leg?
>> Obviously was not a joke. It was
Schroinger's joke, right? Because it's a
joke when you call them out on it, but
they're actively spreading this rumor,
right? They're actively spreading this
rumor.
>> I just
>> Oh, he touched on
>> What do you even say to this man? What
do you even say to this?
>> We not laughing.
>> It's the sexual harassment HR meme. It
is. It is. Tell me you wouldn't be
traumatized if Wick touched your leg.
Come on. Who here? Who here can say Who
here can say they would not be
traumatized if witch wick touched their
leg. Okay. Need an hourong shower. I'd
need therapy. I'd be traumatized if
Destiny or Wick did that, says Addie. I
feel sick, says Hey, it's Lissy. I'd
have eight showers and use three
different loofah.
Okay. Endless fake, especially bare leg.
Yeah. I mean, that's just terrifying
stuff. Really? That's just nasty.
>> And it's hidden within jokes, right? The
accusation itself is hidden within kind
of laughter and things like that. But
these are serious allegations, right?
They're joking, quote unquote, but
they're not um that I'm a someone who
sexual.
>> It's very, very serious allegation that
you touched Ringer Ramoth's thigh
without consent. Very serious allegation
here. Wick
>> this is women. And look, maybe you could
say that if this was isolated, but
remember Bug Squatter is a person who
DM'd Mantis to for to try to paint me as
a sex pest as well to get her logs to
paint me someone who'd been sexually
harassing Mantis as well. Right. This
was an active campaign.
>> Yeah. Cuz she was invit
me as this that they're still doing to
this day. And now let's see what because
uh Ginger Ramoth DM'd me recently and
it's it's worth looking at. Right?
Because oh hold on let me adjust it so
you can see because you don't see the
first Here we go. So she just and this
isn't this is unprompted the other day,
right? Um says the amount of people and
this is her the amount of people that
want to make something out of that
picture of your hand on my knee is
crazy. And remember at the time the the
things that you didn't see in the chat
is she was telling them actively this
ain't this ain't anything. This is
nothing right.
>> No leave alone. No.
>> Okay. Okay. Ring around.
>> I say yeah it's very annoying a lot with
everything they've tried to dig up on me
that this is the worst they got. And she
says yeah it's a big nothing. Lol. I say
yep. I don't know how many times I've
had to explain to people that you did
nothing wrong. Lol. And again what does
this imply to you? Does this imply to
you that they were joking? Does this
imply to you that they were just like,
"Haha, we're not being serious about
it." Does this imply to you that people
didn't actually think that I had done
something wrong here? It does not. It
implies that people consistently ask her
and be like, "Yo, did Wick did Wick
[__] molest you? Did Wick [__]
grope you? Did Rick [__] assault
you?" Right? Because it's it's this
hiding in this drug. Wick is a Wick is a
victim unironically of the the sexual
harassment HR meme. That's what's
happening here. Anyone else if they saw
that picture and they saw that clip and
a joke about it, just pass him by. But
Wick's uh Wick's appearance is just so
uh concerning. People are compelled to
just they just have to double check.
When you call him out, it's a joke.
Haha. But it actively pushes a narrative
that you're a thing. And so I say, "Mind
if I release these DMs or better yet, uh
we do a little stream segment together?"
Um, she said, "Uh, let me get it." Oh,
hold on.
>> You go on stream and tell everyone I'm
not a total rapist, please.
>> She says, "Lol, you can share this combo
if you'd like, but I'll stay out of the
rest of it. I'll always stand by that
you didn't do anything wrong that night
and in fact that you helped me get out
of an uncomfortable situation that
night, which is also true, but I won't
talk about the details." But yeah,
that's that that's what made it like
super offensive to [__] hero.
>> I actively I I was not just a gentleman.
I was a [__] hero. Okay. D. No way.
Hey man, leave her alone. Hey man. Hey
man. Hey man, leave her alone. I'm a
hero. I'm a hero.
Dude, this is awesome. God, that's epic.
That's just [__] epic, isn't it? This
guy's a Chad. What was he said to Moral
Day? I I [__] [__] I [__] [__]
>> Helped me get out of an uncomfortable
situation that night, which is also
true, but I won't talk about the
details. But yeah, that's that that's
what made it like super offensive to me.
Like I actively I I was not just a
gentleman. I was a [__] hero. Okay,
I'm going to be real. And
>> damn that's hard, bro.
>> Um yeah, this isn't a joke, gang.
>> Clearly. Clearly. I mean, we all saw the
clip.
>> But yeah, this is something that's been
going on for years. And this is a tactic
that they use. Schrodinger's joke,
right? And they will make that big
raised hand.
>> Thank you, Jimy, for the $5. Thank you.
>> And yeah, this is what happens. So,
yeah, it's a it's a big tactic tactic
that Quimman uses a lot. It's very
popular. Okay.
>> Yeah, I was I was really pushing that
serious. That was, you know,
>> harrowing footage of me pushing a false
allegation against Wick. He just showed
there. Really, that's that's the thing,
man. Is sometimes it's serious and
sometimes it's a joke. You just never
tell which that harrowing footage
>> replied instead of like explaining it or
anything like that. He replied,
>> "Why? Why you Why don't you explain
Explain the joke to me on Twitter right
now. Explain the joke to me on Twitter
right now." No. No. I don't think I
will. No.
>> Me a gift of me dancing. And again,
does he think this is going to embarrass
me? This was on stream. I was busting
some [__] moose, right? I was getting
down.
>> I'm not sure if he knows the
connotations of goodbye horses. I'm
honestly unsure if he he's quite aware
of the connotation of the edit that I'm
posting there. The joke isn't even
necessarily just him dancing.
>> A gift of me dancing. And again,
does he think this is going to embarrass
me? This was on stream. I was busting
some [__] moves. He was he was
busting some [__] moves. That's
facts.
>> I enjoy them.
>> That's facts.
>> You got to give it to him.
>> Look at him go, man. That's full front
on you that he dude.
That goes crazy. No. Look at him. He's
getting back into it, too.
Big fan of dancing alone in his room to
goodbye horses, it seems.
Really into that.
Reading too much insight is defamatory
by the way.
>> I I want to want to dance a little more,
but fair done. Like, yeah, I got moves.
Stay jealous, [__] queen. Okay, I
don't know what to talk to tell you.
Yeah, I'm going to dance. I don't give a
[__] if you guys clip me. I don't give a
[__] because I know what joy feels like.
Okay,
>> you'll never take as whimsy.
>> I know what it's like to be happy.
You'll never take Wick's whimsy.
>> Is anyone else feeling that big Wick
energy? Raised hand emoji
>> with $5. Huge appreciation, Jimly. Thank
you. It's true, Rise. It's true. I would
never dance on stream. It's true.
>> I don't give a [__] if you don't like my
dancing. This ain't a [__] strip
club. I ain't dancing for your
>> Could have fooled me.
>> What are you doing? Imagine being
someone who is so scared to dance
because someone might [__] videotape
them or record them and put it on the
internet and laugh at them. Who? Who the
[__] cares? [__] get your get your
game on, bros. Get out there. Do your
dance. Shake that ass, baby. Right.
Like, what are you
>> How's it going for you?
>> My life would be worse. My life would be
worse. I would be less happy.
>> I couldn't dance.
>> Scared of dancing.
>> My dancing was taking my dancing. My
moves.
>> $20.
>> Taken away from me.
>> Sorry. I'm sorry. 10 pounds. Uh from Riz
what the buck says. Dance break. True. 7
Canadian dollars from Big Leafy Tree. He
says, "There's an excellent skit on
irony poisoning called Hanging Out with
Your Edgeord Friend by Ryan the Leader.
I might check it out sometime." Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you.
>> That sounds incredibly
>> funny. During the dance segment, we had
a little boost in viewership there. So,
uh, uh, back to it. Yeah. So, they will
demand that you hold yourselves in
principles. You don't ha, you don't hang
around doctors. You don't hang around
people who do bad actions, but they're
hanging around Queenman. They're hanging
around Ch Logic. They're hanging around
all these people who either allow bad
actions in their spaces or do the bad
actions themselves because they want you
to follow a principle that they will
never hold themselves to.
>> Literally do literally do I literally do
I literally do hold the principle. I
literally do show how I'm not
>> cuffs. Okay. They want to use your we uh
uh principles against you as handcuffs
or a weapon. That's it. Okay. So that's
the fourth tactic that you'll see a
demand.
>> Yeah. Also, funny note here, by the way,
guys. He he rants out all this [__] and
he tries to group me in here and when
Dan comes on later, I don't know how
much of it will get. When Dan comes on
later, thank the membership. Blame me
like Dan's just like, "Oh yeah, Queenman
Queen's not involved." And you know, to
the extent he was, he was pushing back
on the [__] [__] and telling me to
stop as he said multiple times already.
It's just like what? So, so you retards
going to stop grouping me in yet? cuz
even even Dan's saying this
>> uh unilateral demand for principles and
restraint. Okay. The fifth tactic, no
win framing. Anything you do that isn't
furthering their goals is painted as
bad. If you wait to give a response uh
for more evidence, you're hiding. Why
are you hiding, bro? Why you sweeping?
Why aren't you talking about this
allegation right now? If you respond to
the allegations, bro spiraling. Bro is
spiraling. Look at him. He's crashing
out in real time. Look at him. Look at
him go. If you provide evidence.
>> Okay. You are literally crashing out
over jokes, though, Wick. Let's be Let's
just be totally real here. You literally
are crashing out over jokes.
>> You're drama farming, bro. What are you
doing? You're attacking me, bro. You're
trying to drama farm. No matter who the
[__] saying that,
>> no matter what action you take, it's
going to be painted against you as a
negative. Just understand that. They
don't care what you do. They care how
they're going to frame it. And that's
the only thing that they're looking at
is how can we frame this action that
Wick is taking or this streamer is
taking or this chatter is taking or
anyone whoever their target is. How can
we frame it as negative? How can we
frame it as bad? No matter what they do,
you can't win, right? They won't let
you. They will frame everything.
>> Same [__] I I need to like eat, man.
>> Yeah. You failed to understand the hole
you're digging. You're looping, right?
Oh, bro's just uh Bro's not addressing
the allegations. He must be sweeping.
>> Yeah, some yummy ramen perhaps. Some
delicious ramen.
>> Panos of Rivia says, "I'm going to start
you calling you Wolverine instead of
Wick cuz god damn, that spine of yours
is made of adamantium." Well, thank you.
I do appreciate that. Another thing they
do is victim reversal. This is an
>> I saw Soy Pill post this, man. This was
awesome.
Hey, I'll [__] suck your dick. You
want me to eat yummy ramen? I'll eat
your [__] yummy ramen. This is hate
>> that I want to frame, right, to to kind
of let you guys know. Um, they will
provoke you.
>> A succulent Japanese meal.
>> They will harass you. They will target
you and when you react to it,
>> old man Frogan,
>> right? JTO's going to say, "Oh my god,
>> Wick is making baseless allegations
against me." Right.
>> Yeah. I uh I'm one of the main active
people on a server that's targeted you
specifically and we're targeting people
around you uh because of your
association to Destiny. But you reacting
to that is a problem because you're
coming after me. I'm the victim here. Um
your reaction to what they do to you
becomes the evidence against you.
>> I mean sometimes, yeah, that's legit.
Sometimes if your response to being
mocked is to freak the [__] out, start
like making up a bunch of lies and
pushing them as part of like some psycho
doxers insane campaign. Yeah, that is
that is good evidence against you.
>> Your reaction to being doxed, harassed,
having your life gone through with fine
tooth.
>> So again, like yeah, Wick has some room
for grievance there, but it was handled
firmly the moment it was reported. So I
I just don't know what more can be done
past that.
>> Put out uh made fun of constantly. Your
reaction to that, right? Very human to
be like, "What the [__] bro? What are
you doing, bro?"
>> I mean, under Wig's definition, it
wasn't even a dogs, but hey,
>> is seen as evidence against you? Because
now you're attacking them unfairly. And
remember, all these tactics kind of uh
kind of work together. they kind of uh
uh meld together and they uh they'll
switch between and use different ones as
they go. But this is a very common one
that they do. One of the things that uh
Queman and I'm I'm making specific
allegations here. Queman has said that I
have I have secret docs information that
I'm holding.
>> Oh yeah. So I mentioned prefil stream
the other other day. I am going to just
skip past this. Honestly, if Wick wanted
to, you know, address this offline, I'd
be more than happy to. Um, but I don't
get into like the intricacies of what's
accurate dogs information, all this
[__] So, I'm just not
>> right. We're already
>> I don't I don't operate like Wick.
>> Well, Wick is running cover for
Destiny's sex crime, which I
specifically did not do. I specifically
condemned these things. Pretty sure I
didn't say that. And as it went, I'm
like, this is not okay. This is not
morally okay. This was this was this was
a bad thing. A very very bad thing,
right? But because I'm still working
with him and you like just working with
a bad guy just isn't enough for most
people. They have to paint me as someone
who's defended his actions, every single
one of his actions. And again, none of
this has to be true because remember,
I've had yelling and screaming matches
on stream with this guy, right? On
several topics that we have fundamental
disagreements on, right? And that's the
way they create this permission
structure is normally, yeah, these guys
aren't destiny. Why are we going after
him? But it's okay to harass, to target,
to docks even if I'm defending a rapist.
If I'm defending someone who has done
sex crimes now, it's a little more
justified in people's minds. Right? This
is the tactic. This is the
>> Oh, well then you can't talk about
things that you believe to be gross
sexual misconduct then because what if
what if someone thinks the person's evil
and does something about it like think
of the world you're setting up here wick
tactic this is what they do and they
push it as far as they can get and they
this is something they flooded the zone
with to be clear they've gone into voice
channels they've gone into chat they've
super chat
>> discord users talk
>> uh gone into discords um their private
group chats that they have other private
group chats. Some of their members will
be uh were also in um DMs with their
friends um friends who aren't related to
all this, right? By the way, um to
different streamers discords, right?
This this this planting of a permission.
>> It is literally it's like kirkism
arguments, man. It is like call
conservatives Nazis because what if they
get shot? That's like what's being said,
basically.
>> It's a very effective tactic. What are
we on? Nine. Yeah, we're on nine. Sorry,
I'm worked up gang. I'm worked up a
little. Can we take A STRETCH BREAK?
>> STRETCH. BIG STRETCH. Big stretch,
ladies and gentlemen. Big stretch.
Good to get the blood flow. Good to get
the wiggles out. Good to get the
wiggles. Love it. We love it. Now, here
we go. Step nine. And I see this
happening in chat, too. Hey, Twitch, I'm
looking at you. Uh, you maximize yours
and you minimize theirs. And what does
that mean? anything done to you, you
paint in the maximally bad light, right?
I've seen this happen on Twitter, right?
Um, claims by different streamers.
>> It's just it's just like crazy because
the actions of one side are like
massively massively massively
disproportionate. It just is true. and
different people, some of them don't
stream anymore, that I have uh that I
was harassing Connor, that I was
harassing counterpoints, right? What did
I actually do? I disagreed with the way
he was handling it and I confronted him
about it.
>> Harassment in no stretch the imagination
have I been harassing counterpoint.
Quite the opposite, in fact. But because
I questioned, right, the peop the person
that they were [__] mind raping, um
I'm I'm harassing counterpoints. I'm
stalking counterpoints. I'm going after
counterpoints. That's the narrative.
>> Yeah, it sounds [__] that they're
saying that. I agree.
>> Planting, right?
>> It's kind of my point.
>> And they'll minimize what they do. And
you see this all the time. They're like,
bro, we just have a clipping channel.
That's it. It's just clipping. That's
all we're doing. Oh, is it a crime to
criticize Destiny? Is it a crime to have
a problem with what he's doing? No, it's
not. But that's not what you're doing.
>> So, explain that. You are minimizing
the what's being done harassment
campaign that you have built and are
targeting.
>> Explain where the harassment is.
>> Not only Destiny
>> harassment is absolutely not encouraged.
There's no literally no benefit to
doxing harassment taking stuff IRL.
There's literally no benefit to any of
the what could be seen as like uh you
know figures of authority, right? Nobody
gives a [__] about getting anyone doxed.
So she does not benefit content creators
in any way.
>> Incline
>> apart from obviously Destiny who was
attempting to just you know scare people
weaker than him in submission.
>> Um anyone associated with them who
doesn't disavow. Um that is not just we
have criticisms and are expressing them.
There's a fundamental difference here.
And and this is what they'll do when you
call it out and none of the other
tactics work. They can't deflect from
it. They can't distract from it. They
can't go on offense. They can't move the
goalpost. They'll minimize it. And
they'll minimize what happens to you,
too, right? They'll minimize,
and we've talked about this before,
right? But they'll minimize what happens
to you. Like, all you did, all I he did
was dox you, bro. And yeah, that's bad.
And we disavow it. But Destiny has done
so much worse to us. He doxed us.
>> Yes, Wick. He doxed a bunch of innocent
people. Yes, Wick. Yes, we understand
that people have done bad things to you,
too. Those have been firmly dealt with.
Meanwhile, Destiny continues to do
insane [__] to totally innocent people.
That's you see the problem here, Wake
Double. If they didn't have double
standards, they wouldn't have any
standards at all. Um, they drive wedges
um between uh me and Destiny. Like one
of the things that has happened uh
recently is a lot of people tried to
drive a wedge and say Destiny's trying
to control your content, bro. Destiny
secretly hates you, bro. Destiny called
food chops his biggest defender, bro.
Don't you feel [__] uh don't you feel
[__] uh insulted by that? I don't I
don't give a [__] what he thinks, right?
Like, I'm not doing this. I want to make
this very clear. I'm not doing this for
>> Wow. people being mean about your
relationship with Destiny on Twitter.
Dude, it's that's terrible. That's
really awful, Wick. That's horrible.
Good boy Pats or accolades. If I didn't
believe it, I wouldn't say it. So, he I
don't at a certain point I don't I don't
really give a [__] what he thinks about
me. If he thinks I'm [__] okay, I
am saying what I believe to be true. And
if he thinks I'm [__] he thinks I'm
[__] I don't give a [__] He might
not even like me. I don't care. Why are
his front teeth a different color to the
rest of his teeth? Um, now if you played
uh from if you're a big FromSoft fan,
you'll be familiar with a concept called
environmental storytelling. Um, now
Wick,
where do I even start?
I I forget all the story to be honest.
Basically, Wick had a GoFundMe ago. It's
one of the reasons he hates me so much.
He ran a GoFundMe a few years ago for a
few thousand dollars or something. I
forget the exact amount. Don't quote me.
Um, and he had it fulfilled and then he
took like two years to get his teeth
fixed. He got new veneers cuz his old
ones fell out or broke or whatever the
[__] cuz he broke his teeth at some
point. Um, yeah. So, he fundraed for new
veneers and took took ages to get them.
So, I was flaming him before he got them
being like, "Where's the money, Wick?
Post receipts. Post receipts." Because
it was taking so long. Um, so that
that's why some of Wick's teeth are a
totally different color
>> here. This isn't about him liking me.
This is about me saying what I think is
correct and let the consequence follow
from that. Okay? Let the consequences
follow. So I've I've now that I know
that there's this organized campaign, I
am looking at all this in a very
different light. I see the tactics that
you guys are trying to do. I see the
wedges that you guys are trying to drive
there. And bro, you're an OP. It's an
op. You're trying to manipulate me.
Nightmare. Nightmare.
>> It's going to have the opposite effect
of what you intend. it's going to cement
me against you. And I wanna I want to
just take this moment to kind of like be
a little uh a little more open than I
I'm comfortable with with you because I
think it's important. Um because this
kind of plays into why I'm making the
decisions I am. There's been a lot of
people in my communities. You guys
[__] you guys have hurt me,
>> dude. Yeah. Wait, no. I saw this bit. Oh
my god. This is beautiful, guys. Guys,
this is great. This is peak wick. We
really do get some absolute wick kino
here, man.
>> This kind of plays into why I'm making
the decisions I am. There's been a lot
of people in my communities. You guys
[__]
>> warning. This streamer is crossing the
parasocial border. Max
>> lot of people I'm making this
communities. There's been a lot of
people in my communities. You guys
[__] You guys have hurt me.
I feel I feel like I thought you guys
liked me. Oh, wick. No.
>> I thought you guys thought I was cool. I
thought you guys enjoyed my takes.
>> I thought you thought I thought you guys
thought I was cool. I thought you liked
me. Thought you [__] with me.
Oh my god. We do like you, Wick. We do
like you. I actually don't like Wick. I
actually really don't like Wick. So, I'm
not even going to front. I'm not even
going to front. I actually really do not
like this guy. However, this is very
funny.
>> Is anyone else feeling that big Wick
energy? raised hand emoji.
>> Thank you for the $5. Huge appreciate,
Jimly. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Everybody loves Wick. I'm sorry. The
They're just like the Spurouts did it
for me, man. The the PV stuff like back
in the day, unironically, right? Just a
bit of Wick history here. Bit Wickstery.
Um Wick first showed up and was noted in
any way because of this stuff where him
and this guy Madlad were attacking Dylan
Burns for his trip to Ukraine or Poland
or whatever the [__] he was doing. and
they were like, "You're a war tourist."
or some [__] like that. Then he start he
was either already doing his own panels
and started doing his own panels. He was
just called Death of Certainty and it
would he call himself Wick and uh but
the show was Death of Certainty. And so
he did that for a while and Chud would
go on them. And the way me and DK first
started really interacting was was with
this wicking out joke that we'd started
in chat uh where we we would you know
anytime Wick would like over moderate
like get too involved think his opinion
mattered too much it would be like an
ironic oh I'm looking out I'm working
out you know and then it started getting
worked into like this like there was
like a [__] element brought into it
where it would be where you talk about,
you know, wicked out of your wife
getting [__] and this sort of [__]
like a [__] element to the wick jokes.
And then DK made a bunch of edits of
like movie posters that included the
wick like the wicker man and all this
[__] So we started from that and then
in Chilo's panels it'd be like sort of a
semi-ironic sort of like mocking but
kind of you know affectionate in a way
mocking and Wick would be more involved
in Ch's community and [__] and basically
people bullied him into changing his
name from death of certainty to just
Wick TV because it was like absurd that
he was still trying to hang on to this
death of certainty thing where it's
terrible branding. Um so people just
like you just got to change the name
change name. So he did that obviously a
great move, great advice people were
giving him. And I think what he ended up
getting upset about was someone recorded
I think like some lav drama that
happened in his VC in his server and so
he totally spurred out and cut off Chel
and cut off everyone from all that and
yeah he said he had a bee in his bonnet
pretty bad after that and then all the
mocking the mocking just got to him. So,
you know, there was always a there was
always a path for Wick to stay cool with
everyone, even if people would still be
mocking him, but he really just does not
take well to to uh the right of
commentary.
>> I feel I feel like I thought you guys
liked me. I thought you guys thought I
was cool. I thought you guys enjoyed my
takes and my contents and thought of me
as an honest person. At least you guys
[__] you guys have hurt me.
>> There's no shame in losing to laugh.
>> I feel I feel like I thought you guys
liked me. I thought you guys thought I
was cool. I thought you guys enjoyed my
takes and my contents and thought of me
as an honest person at least and someone
with principles and someone who's
legitimate. But I found out recent like
a lot don't like I felt like I was
drowning right during all of this when I
found out all this and it kind of all
hit me at once and a lot of things took
on a way different light once I was uh
some of these puzzle pieces got revealed
to me, right? I was [__] drowning. I
was I was looking for like oh man I what
am I going to do? Am I going to even
[__] stream anymore, right? And I was
looking at
>> no Wick. No
>> ways to
>> Oh, right. I literally I don't want him
to quit streaming. Why the [__] would I
want Wick to quit quit streaming? I make
money covering Wick. It's If he thinks
that's what's happening here, that
people want him to quit streaming. No
one wants him to quit streaming. He's a
funny character. It's like what? It's
like when Sugar and Spice ended.
Devastating, you know. devastating. I'll
never forgive Destiny.
>> You thread the needle to like, okay,
well, I'm not I'm not going to let
someone control my content, but this guy
has kind of a point and I see what he's
what's happening to him, right? Destiny,
I'm I'm talking about Destiny. Like in
this specific example, like I I under
like I I heard through the grapevine
that Destiny was thinking abandoning
everyone who had Doobie in their
Discord, right?
>> Wow.
>> And blacklisting everyone. He didn't
want anything to do with them, right?
And so I was like, you know, I kind of
get why. I understand it. But at the
same time, I was like, I'm not I'm not
going to ban him if he didn't break a
[__] rule. So I was like, well, I
could talk to him and we could have a
conversation and maybe we can come to a
compromise, right, where we both get
what we want. I don't allow you to
dictate who I have and who I don't have
in my server, but I also provide you
some access so that people can't have
secret [__] snarker meetings in my
VC, right? Without being challenged or
without being exposed for that. So, I
came up with what I meet perfect
solution.
>> People talking negative about
>> it wasn't a great solution, but it was a
solution to the problem where a I didn't
have to ban Dubie or anyone that I
didn't want to, and b uh now
>> Yeah. Yeah, like I said, he fell out
with Ch and the old community over
someone leaking a recording of some live
drama on his server. So, this was like a
thing he really cared about and he he
gave up on it.
>> Doesn't feel like he has uh no recourse
against people who are secretly talking
[__] behind his back. And so I set that
up and yeah, the rule change may not
have been perfect uh that I put together
and it's not an ideal solution and I
know it's going to inconvenience people
who are in my community, but when I when
I announced it to the well well when I
streamed it, when I announced it to
people, they were acting like I had
[__] like killed their pet and I was
in a situation where I had just been
doxed. I just found out I was a victim,
a continual victim.
>> Might sound crazy. It might sound crazy,
Wick, but I feel like people in your
Discord might just want to be able to
like talk freely without being blown up
by some like 10K view streamer. I know.
Crazy suggestion.
>> Harassment campaign. And I was trying to
I was trying to keep from being
blacklisted, right? Uh I was trying to
keep like control of my content as well.
I was trying to do all these things and
juggle all these uh competing incentives
and responsibilities and trying to
protect people in my server, right, from
getting from getting banned. I'm not
going to let people just tell me [__]
ban anyone. I'm just not going to do
that. Um, and they had and because these
server rules would minorly inconvenience
them in their VC habits, they acted like
I had killed their pet and I was [__]
drowning. And I'm sorry that you feel
that way, gang. I do. And adjusted
things. And we made the rule better. And
we're going to talk about changes to my
rules of engagement later in the thing.
But I felt like, man, my community just
is this what you do? Right? Like I
needed help. I needed someone to have my
back. I needed my I I was I thought my
my community at least would understand
and be like, "Yeah, I get it. It's not
the best." And uh it's not ideal, but we
got you, boy. Um but the initial
reaction from some was crazy.
>> He's so Mormon, bro. He's so [__]
Mormon. It's crazy, bro. now since we've
made up and uh there was tensions high
and I snapped and people snapped and
we're good now and we've kind of like
gotten over that, right? But uh yeah, at
the time I felt like I felt like [__]
betrayed and sucking [__] hurt.
Sucks. Sucks. Um so yeah, it's made me
rethink how I engage in this space and
it made me all of this has made me see
what Destiny goes through in a different
light. And I was neutral before. I tried
to maintain a professional distance
before, but especially after seeing what
happened with Connor and Destiny, I
don't think that's the move. So, no.
>> Conor was right.
>> Destiny's a homie now. Destiny has had
my back in a real way that people I
thought were my homies didn't. Destiny
has provided me with what he didn't have
to to be clear. provided me with
content. He's provided me with a
platform. He's he's helped me out. He
has invited me into his spaces when Look
gang, I'm kind of boring in some way.
>> This guy help me. I'm on his channel.
>> I'm kind of boring. All right, man.
>> He doesn't get anything from me. Not in
a real way. I got like [__] 100
viewers. He's not He's not boosting his
content. I I do provide some value. I I
I will say, but right like he's done me
a favor. This guy is legit like some
caricature of like cartoon henchmen, you
know? Do you know what I mean? It's just
like it's bizarre. It's bizarre. Please
take a look in the mirror, man. He's
he's helped me out. He has invited me
into his spaces when Look, gang, I'm
kind of boring in some ways. I'm kind of
boring. He doesn't get anything from me.
Not in a real way. I got like [__]
100 viewers. He's not he's not boosting
his content. I I do provide some value.
I I will say, but right like he's done
me a solid. He's crazy and he has had my
back and he is going after the people
who's gone after me, right? I don't
pretend that he's doing it entirely
altruistically, right? But ah if if this
amount of harassment that I have
received, this amount of targeting that
I have received is a reflection being as
small as I am being just a secondary
target is a reflection of what he's been
going through. Damn. [__] damn. It
really it changed my perspective.
>> So no one can talk about him negatively
anymore.
>> And look, I don't approve of every
single thing he does or do. I'm not
>> even engag
I'm I'm not [__] gonna do everything
he says, but I'm gonna have his back,
too. I am now on team destiny. My
neutrality is over.
>> It's It's over now. Now he's on team
Destiny, guys. Just tell you because
they've had my Now, this this time
>> I don't like everything.
>> I have made takes when I've disagreed
with Destiny. You know what they do?
They You know what? You know what DGG
does? They make mean Reddit posts about
me. They will sometimes sometimes make
mean tweets at me and ask me. Sometimes
they'll block me on Twitter. Sometimes
they'll come into my Discord and mouth
off. Right. That's annoying. It is. I
won't pretend it's not. Especially when
they mischaracterize me. That's
annoying. It's annoying. Right. But that
is not the same as what these snarker
[__] have been doing. Not the same at
all. These snarker
>> I just love his face, man. is have
harassed me, have constantly lied about
me, have doxed me, have doxed my
co-host, HAVE DOXED MY [__]
>> like he's literally looping in like Kiwi
Farm [__] It's just so crazy that what
they're getting away with here, man.
>> Bro, these are not the same. And I am
not going to pretend that they are. Not
at all. So yeah, doesn't mean I'm not
going to disagree with Destiny when he's
[__] wrong. But no, team DGG, bros,
give me the patch. I wear it proudly
with that.
>> Crazy, man.
>> A reminder though that this how this is
going to be painted, right? And this is
a call back to the beginning of the
stream that people are going to be
saying, I'm selling out when it's in
fact the opposite.
>> Right. Of course,
>> many of my friends in this space will
not approve of this of this uh of this
decision. Right. They won't like it at
all. They don't like Destiny. And look,
again, they're not snarkers. They just
don't like Destiny. Fair enough, right?
They are going to think less of me for
this. The harassment that I have been
going through is going to ramp up. I am
now in more danger. They are going to
hurt me more. I'm going to be
legitimized more as a target. Right?
Money from donations from people who've
been giving me money and donations is
going to stop. I am probably going to
lose money off of this. Right? probably.
I don't know. Uh there's different
factors at play. Uh this is blowing up
um my viewers and things like that. So
it might even out in the end. I don't
know. But the incentive structure at
play is for me to cast off Destiny. Like
that's why counter one of the reasons,
not the only reason, maybe not the main
reason. Um there look, I'm not I'm not
touching that. They they got their own
issues. Okay. Um but yeah that's why a
lot of people have cut off Destiny
because there it's incentive like
there's incent they are incentivized to
do so it will there is a lot of
>> most people just like torch their main
you know political connection for just
no reason mainstreamer political
connection for just no reason they just
it's like crazy how can you possibly
think it is self-interest people are
cutting Destiny off for these people
Destiny the people Destiny keeps around
are people that don't have many other
avenues news a lot of the time. Yeah,
Snark pays dividends. That's it. All
these people like snark streamers now,
right? Of course everywhere. That's what
Connor is doing now, right? There's a
lot of money. There's a lot of
attention. There's a lot of social uh
clout to be gained. There's a lot of
incentives and it's constant the
pressure to just disavow destiny there.
Don't let them pretend otherwise. But I
gota I gotta call balls and strikes. I
gotta stand up. I gotta stand up on
principles. I gotta stand up and say I
don't care. I You ain't I ain't [__]
scared of you. I ain't [__] scared of
you, snarkers. Uhuh. You're not going to
>> food shops have way more viewers if she
just went anti-destiny. You know,
>> bully me into doing something I don't
believe in. You're not going to bully me
out of this [__] space. You're not
going to bully me into casting off
someone that you think is a super bad
evil whatever, right? You're just not.
This ain't about money. It's about
standards and it's about I don't let the
terrorists win. And that's why they do
it though because it works. But it ain't
gonna work with me. You made an enemy of
me. And this was the stupidest [__]
thing you could have done. I would have
remained neutral because I didn't know.
But you decided to make an enemy of me.
>> Devil shivers. Nice guy is cool.
>> What? Now the truth claims of a lot of
things don't [__] matter anymore
because you're the ones attacking me and
DG's the ones defending me. I don't
know.
>> Okay, Jim. I don't know. Um,
>> all right, man. I'm gonna get [__] for
this.
>> Else feeling that big. I already
see the tweets and I already see all
that. I already see the clips. But yeah,
BG
>> clips, not the clips.
>> Okay, if you guys want this to stop, if
you want to deescalate this space, it's
it's going to be real easy.
>> So, this is just crazy
>> cuz I don't I don't [__] like drama.
I don't I
>> This is just crazy. The standard over
here is no dog singing. Period. None of
that [__] Never has been any different.
Never has been. And yet they're saying,
"Oh, you have you have to disarm. You
have to disarm." Yeah, we're not doing
it, bro. The one point uh that was
pointed the one post was pointed out was
moderated and it was one post.
Meanwhile, there has been an active
campaign of doxing against numerous
communities. Dip my toes now and again,
but I really don't like it. It's not fun
for me. So, if you guys just stop, I'll
stop talking about you. If you guys just
stop, I'll just stop, too. It's easy.
>> Okay. No one cares if you talk about
people. Wick. You can talk all you want.
>> Right. You just stop coming at me and
I'll I'll just shut up.
>> Please keep talking.
>> Stop coming after Destiny. Stop coming
after all those around him. Stop being
unhinged [__] weirdos. And when I say
come at, I don't mean you can't
criticize a guy. I'm going to criticize
a guy. I think he's going some of his
takes are [__] stupid. And some of
the things he's done is wrong. Just
immoral and wrong. He has. Right. But
like you keep coming at him and you keep
coming at me.
>> Oh, there it is. Right.
>> Then we're going to have to have we have
an issue.
>> There it is. Just stop talking. Just
stop talking. Okay. No, I'll pass.
>> We can be at peace. We can deescalate.
And I've talked to a lot of people
around here. No one likes what this
community, what this space, what this
larger streaming space is becoming,
right? No one really likes it. They
don't like it. It feels bad. It feels
yucky.
>> Let's deescalate together. Okay. We can
we can compromise. We can obviously you
guys can you guys can
>> I mean I mean I say stop not wick I mean
he's not the one doing it
>> on Destiny all you like but this
harassment
>> obviously clear
>> needs to [__] stop. You stop and
Destiny will stop too. It's that easy.
And and I'll make you this promise. I'll
make you this promise. Okay. If you stop
and he doesn't then me and Destiny are
I'm no longer on team Destiny.
>> Never started, dude. Literally never
started. It was has always been
bannable. Literally dealt with the
moment we know about it. So, literally
never started.
>> It's that simple. That simple. So, you
know, DG may not like that, right? But
that's a principle I hold. Um, and
that's the claim I'm making. Cool. Okay.
And with that with that with that with
that changes are going to be made to my
rules of engagement engagement. Okay. We
already talked about one, but I'm also
going to change how my space is
moderated. Okay. Okay. And this is this
is something that's been cooking for a
little bit. And I I I did not make the
same mistake I made before. And I want
to make sure um to make this clear. So,
I'm just going to read this. I had my
admin uh wrote this up. And I think it's
useful to just kind of read this out
loud.
>> The game's changed.
>> And uh kind of give you it's it's not
strictly a rule change, but it's more
like a a vibe change, if you will. Um
so, I'm just going to read it. Quick
community rules update because this [__]
has gotten way too normalized online.
We're gonna crack down hard on cross-
server drama farming, hatewatch
behavior, and the weird obsessive snark
culture that keeps popping up around
streamer communities. And to be super
clear, criticism is fine, disagreement
is fine. Thinking Wick is wrong about
something is fine. Wow. Arguing memes,
push back, calling me [__] calling
take stupid, none of that is going to be
against the rules. What we are done
tolerating, however, is escalation into
non-stop bad faith [__] stirring. Making
insane accusations with zero basis. And
not just against me, against my homies.
To be clear, against the homies. So,
what does this mean? If you are calling
people in dev's community pedophiles
because of an album cover, I'm banning
you. I'm just banning you right now. If
you're making fun of Stardust Pety
or being sick, no, you're not going to
be able to [__] hate on my homies
like that. I am going to protect them a
little bit, okay? I'm going to have
their back.
>> No hating on Wick's homies, guys.
>> So, yeah. Uh, morale
>> stuff budgy dying is funny or whatever
the [__] going on. I liter I literally
have no I literally don't know what's
going on with that. Haven't followed it
at all. Uh, gonna be real. I do not take
any of Stardust's winging, concerned
trolling about offensive comments
seriously in any way. It's like truly
just it's beneath even entertaining.
We're banning you. You've engaged in
this behavior. You're gone. Uh, let me
go to server settings, members. We're
doing it live, gang. I told my uh told
my my admin team to uh hold off on this
cuz I wanted to do it myself. Uh, we're
going to ban you. [__] off. Okay. You're
coming after Dev, coming after Stardust
like that. And we're not talking like I
I think Dev has bad takes and he's
stupid. No, you're you're pedojacking
his community. No. No. I'm
>> jacketing his community.
>> Uh, call the inconsistency police on me.
Put me in handcuffs. What are you doing?
No. My friends are not to be targeted
like that. Disagree with them all you. I
will too. But if you start ped jacketing
people, [__] off. If you start making
>> gay rule gay rule won't be doing that
for any of my friends that's for sure
child logic sex little boys known fact
fact check true by by real queen of all
patriots or their divorce counterpoints
is a homie even though we probably
disagree on a few things and he's
probably not really happy right now but
he's a homie if you're out there
obsessively
uh making fun of his divorce I'm I'm
going to ban you right If you're out
there painting streamers as rapists, I'm
gonna ban you, right? What is the
bisexual, bro? Right. I don't have a
strict line. This is like porn. We know
it when we see it. We know it when we
see it. And I trust my mods. And this
goes for all sides. I want to say this
is a neutral rule. If you are in my
server peding a snarker, you are going
to be banned, too. If you like, we we
just don't do this, right? But I want to
make sure that my homies know I got
their back. And so if you're going after
people's dead pets or their pet that are
sick and you're going to make fun of
them crying when because they're sick or
being worried because they're sick, no,
that's that's inhuman behavior, bro.
What are you doing? [__] off, right?
You're gone. Um, yeah. So, if we catch
you, be warned. Some people have gotten
I'm reading this again. Some people have
gotten way too comfortable acting
completely unhinged online because it's
John streamer drama and we're not
interested in hosting that culture
anymore. This especially applies to the
increasingly weird behavior directed at
Wick and people in this community. If
you have criticisms, say it like a
normal person. If your entire goal is to
spread hate, farm outrage, or
obsessively [__] talk people across
servers, you're going to get
>> something weird about Wick.
>> We want this place to stay opinionated,
funny, argumentative, and chaotic in the
normal way, not the miserable and the
toxic way. Okay, cool. We're good. Okay,
let me read some of these. No gossiping.
I think that's
>> finger wag finger wag got for you guys
and we can do some callins if you guys
want.
>> Okay, so everyone obviously wants to see
uh the call in that made Tony leave the
internet.
>> Um to be honest it's just like kind of
like mad [__] behavior from uh Dan to be
honest. Just like going off to random
chatters and trying to make him blow
everything up.
>> So yeah,
>> but I I just I also just don't
understand why someone like Tony does
this stuff. Do you know what I mean?
like some some people are made to be
debaters, some people are made to be
video assists, some people made to be
clippers, some people should stay
chatters, you know, and I'm sure Tony
could do some of those things. It's best
to avoid the things you're really bad
at. And I would especially advise um not
going on live streams if you're the type
of person to delete everything if
something bad happens. I think generally
going on live streams you should
consider in the worst possible outcome.
What do I do? And if you're if you're
insane the idea you're going to have to
delete everything, it's probably best
just not. Just don't.
>> Hello.
>> Hi. What's up?
>> Hi. What are you?
>> Oh, we've been better. But we're here.
>> Been better.
>> Yeah, you seem to be um you seem to have
some things on your mind lately. Some uh
>> ruminations, we might call them. some
some some considerations that I've been
pondering uh that have been uh cooking
in my brain for a little bit. Yes. No,
that's exactly right. Uh I had a bit of
a revelation recently that has uh
changed my outlook on a few things. A
few revelations actually. Um so yeah um
we've taken that new context into
account and made some changes.
>> Yeah, a few. Are these the ones you were
describing earlier in your stream?
>> Well, depending Yeah. So I I went
through it and uh I went through the
reasons that I've made the decisions I
have how uh certain like destiny and co
and the people around him have gone up
in my credibility because they were
honest to me and people who uh who were
against him have gone down in my
credibility because they lied to me and
uh I think that's perfectly
>> what lies did people tell you?
>> Sure that there was no doxing going on
in that server. They swore to me up and
down there was no doxing and I was shown
evidence that oh look there was doxing
and not only that the server itself
confirmed that that was happening right?
>> Yeah the server confirmed that they
found the instance and they banned the
person.
>> Yeah but that that's like [__] too
late. It's 11 months too late and you
guys had sworn up and down.
>> They banned it as soon as it was brought
to their attention. What do you expect
them to do?
>> It was an obvious doc. Why didn't they
ban him in the first place? I'm not I I
don't know what your docs looks like. I
have no idea what this information would
even look like.
>> Okay.
>> The answer why it wasn't first place is
because it was in the first two weeks of
the server before it was properly
moderated. That that's that's the
answer. Something gets missed, it's you
know, people aren't going back and
checking. You know, if something gets
missed at the time, it's very easy for
it to just slip past.
>> Uh well, I have a number of questions
for you. One was um why not provide the
evidence that you were docs and just
censor the doc? Because I can't
the nature of it. I I can't I can't do
that.
>> You can censor You can censor that part
of it.
>> Well, what do you mean? I It's hard to
describe, right? Because I can't It's
not something like I could show you a a
block of censored material.
>> How do you know that's me? How do you
know that's anyone? How do you know what
that is?
>> But that that would lie on your
credibility. Well,
>> some amount of it would lie on your
credibility. But there's also um [__]
the credibility is the thing. Then you
should probably use my credibility now
to judge whether I'm telling you the
truth or not. I'm telling you, I saw my
doc.
>> You could be saying this based off of
nothing is the issue and you're
expecting us to make like very broad
>> determinations, but they already
admitted it happened. Like, yeah, but I
I don't understand why you are so
willing to jump on board with this when
you will not provide the evidence, even
censored.
>> Okay.
>> Now, we have other instanc
before we move on. Before Before before
we move on, just I I want to say you're
asking me for evidence, but you admit
that it happened and that the Snark
server said that.
>> I have seen their statement
>> is a pointless line of questioning. Yes.
which is which is sadly correct here.
It's a [__] [__] line of
questioning.
>> Not seen the evidence. I have not seen
any of the logs.
>> Hold on.
>> And I don't understand why
>> it's not really spread more because like
Yeah, you there could be parts of it
that allow you to trace it back to the
source and see the PII like any handling
of this. Yes. So the best way to do it
is is basically the ideal way to handle
it is to report stuff privately to
someone that you think is trustworthy
and then which you know I understand is
difficult in this situation but that
that's the best case scenario. Obviously
there's a lot of bad feelings on both
sides. So people probably don't feel
very trusting. But the ideal situation
is you report it to a trustworthy party
or moderator um and just have it removed
and banned as quietly as possible
because you just don't want to draw
attention to you know instances of PI
being being spreading properly. That's
the ideal situation. Just not been
handled here.
>> So do you not believe them when they say
it?
>> Uh not necessarily. I don't know what
was posted, but now we're seeing people
come in and try to accuse this community
of egregious actions. Like I am very
strongly against doxing. I know that
everyone else in the server Oh.
>> Oh,
>> people in the server.
>> Not not everyone in the server, right? A
few people.
>> Hi, Dan.
>> Hold on. I got to I got to fix my
Discord. Hold on one sec.
>> Take your time.
>> See, I Wick. I just don't uh understand
why you don't just censor the
information post what they send At this
point, I think that people have admitted
in the server that my docs happened. I
see no reason to release more
information.
>> That's fine. We can move on to the next
question. You said you would bring on
even terrible people.
>> Yes.
>> To your panel show
>> and uh since you don't regulate
offplatform behavior, would you ever
extend an invit invitation to somebody
like a bad empanada?
>> So yes, in certain context, it would be
content rolled to be clear, but yes, I
would have bad empanada on in different
it depends on the context, right? Um, I
wouldn't have him on for a friendly
chat. We're not gonna play Among Us,
right? But, uh,
>> no, I wouldn't I wouldn't expect I
wouldn't want a chat with that guy to be
friendly. I think he uh
>> Yeah,
>> frankly, I think he should be banned
everywhere. Same with anybody who's on
an open doxing campaign. But,
>> well, we have a we have a thing in our
server where we can we can effectively
ban you from anything but my stream
space, right? So, you can't interact
with the Discord whatsoever. You can't
interact with the members. You can't
type in it. You can't do any of that.
but I can have you on stream. And we did
this and we put this role in place
because there are contexts and
circumstances where I would have someone
who might otherwise be banned, but I
would have them on my show because we
are a free speech platform at the end of
the day.
>> Well, you you say you're a free speech
platform, but you seem to have a problem
with people making certain jokes that
you deem to be crossing a line. Oh,
>> yeah.
>> And I'm confused about why things
>> sucks for not sending our best. Well, I
as far as I know, he wasn't sent. This
is, you know, one of the many reasons
why you would never encourage a chatter
to call in somewhere. You know, many of
them should just stay chatters. Frankly,
>> by specifically mocking Stardust's pet,
as an example,
>> because she's my friend,
>> I'm not I'm not so
big. Like, it's not even a big deal.
Like, what what this is such a [__]
argument. It's not a big deal for wants
to ban people for making fun of Star
Peted and deplatformed. I'm saying you
aren't gonna make fun of my friends in
my space. That's it. Not to a If you
cross a line, if you're a [__]
arsonist and a [__] flinger,
>> then I don't need you in my space. And
if you think that's inconsistent, fine.
Call the consistency police. Have me
arrested.
>> Well, you you manage you manage this.
>> There's literally nothing wrong with
having the standard even. isn't true
like who gives a [__]
>> space and your space in some ways the
rules that you choose to enforce is a
hot inform us in some way about the
principles that you hold and you say
that you hold the principle of free
speech and then you say don't say these
things that I don't like about my
>> yeah it's like gay and lame to be like
don't make fun of my friends but if
that's how you want to moderate the
discord it's up to you ultimately you
know
>> that seems to me to be incoherent
>> free speech means you like a lame
argument from Tony me. Oh, you really
you say you care about free speech, but
I can't make fun of Starless Budgy dying
in your server. Okay, man.
>> I don't think you should be.
>> Is that worse than the [__] put
together?
>> Arrested for it. I can criticize it and
tell people they can't go on your
house.
>> All right. I just think that that is uh
anti-free speech, but we can move on.
>> That's called freedom of association.
It's part of
>> Tony. It's a little uh
>> it's a little what?
>> Good stuff, Dan.
>> Oh, am I disconnect? Hello. brief starts
on raping this chatter.
>> Dan
Dan,
>> it's Dan.
>> I think you're uh
>> I don't know what's wrong with Dan's
setup, but that's Dan. That's not you.
>> Oh, okay. Um I have a few other
questions. Um
>> Dan's failing us right now, but go
ahead, ask your other question.
>> Yeah.
>> Wait, why is Dan even there? Because
rather than like doing anything
productive with his time, Dan wants to
spend all of it like menacing random
nobody retards on Discord who might have
said a negative thing about him at some
point now.
>> Oh yeah, yep. Yep. You're here.
>> Yeah. Okay. Hey Tony, you were How dare
you think that Wick is such a stupid
man? He knows that you're in this
server. Do you think he's read Yeah,
he's read messages you've sent. Now he
may not tell you which one, but they're
not good ones. and you're there looking
at the man and you're like, "Hey, why
can't we be in this server thing I've
done in that server?"
>> Why do you think that I would give you a
heads up so you can try to run ahead of
it?
>> It's cuz there's nothing substantial
there.
>> Sounds like you have nothing to worry
about.
>> Yes. I don't have anything to worry
about. But for some reason, you want to
use this as a list of people to dox when
you know that they aren't doing it to
you and you know
>> that the person who was doxing, you
know, every instance of this, you know,
every instance of this was I got I like
>> remember always
offense. You remember
>> I kind of [__] a way to put it all
but I mean there is a point in there
that is what Dan's kind of doing.
>> Always off.
>> I wanted to ask Wick I wanted to ask
another question.
>> Go for it.
>> So Wick, you said that um people
couldn't pedal jacket others on your
server.
>> Yeah, that that is cracking down on.
Yes.
>> Yeah, sure. That's fair.
>> Um now we have I'm sure you're aware of
food shops.
>> Wait, why did we move off of this issue
again? I'm I'm just going back and it's
that was a very clever move. I was here
when I was talking. Oh, I remember you.
You're interrupting. You're a faculty us
spends all of your time trying to make a
documentary about how you can [__] over
Hutch in the same
>> No, that's not what I'm making.
>> Yeah. And when you're in
basically running kind of gay ops a
little bit against Lonerbox and kind of
being like, "How can we
>> No, that's not what I'm doing.
>> Wait, you're making a video? I can't
even make a video about Hutch. What's
the problem with that, please? I had no
faith in Tony's video about Harch. I'm
going to be real. I'll just be straight
up. Tony's Seems like Tony's left. So, I
just I won't I won't be too nice
anymore. Um I had no faith in that
video. I expect that video to be [__]
terrible. I'd heard about that video.
Zero faith in it whatsoever. This guy
been working on that [__] for like eight
months. I'd heard about it non-stop. I
say non-stop, I mean, you know, with
with regular frequency. And it just, you
know, I I I couldn't tell you even what
a point of it was. Yeah. Yeah, it was
like a full Hutch life deconstruction.
Like, nobody cares that much, dude.
Nobody cares that much. Make a video
about how he's [__] about like one
point and and and do that, you know?
10-minute video, 15-minute video, why
Hutch is [__] about X. That's all
you need, dude. That's all you [__]
need.
>> I mean, they have the logs to find out.
>> So, yes, you will find out when we find
out that there is nothing in here.
>> We're going to find out. He has the
>> I mean, it's kind of it's kind of like
it's kind of fun, right? I mean, I
thought you were a loner box homie, but
you're like a loner box not homie, which
is really
>> making me sad.
>> This is one of the This is one of the
things there, Dan. I I love it.
>> This is one of
>> I thought he was a homie, but he's a not
homie.
>> This is one of the things that is really
frustrating that these people because of
the lot of the people who are viewers of
Lonerbox, who are viewers of Wick, who
are viewers of Dylan Burns, who are
viewers of all these people are former
viewers of Destiny. I learned about all
these people because I used to be a
Destiny viewer. I have been in these
spaces for a long time. A lot of the
people who dislike Destiny now were
already integrated into these into
>> I mean this is just true. This is just
obviously true
>> spaces before. So that's part of why I
think I like like you said earlier that
you thought
>> people watch a lot of different content.
Their tastes change and things happen
that put them off certain content
creators and they are interested in new
things. people like deliberately
infiltrate spaces.
>> Yeah,
>> but because it's not in their favor
right now, they're crying about it
basically is what it comes down to.
>> I mean, you and I find that
>> you find that what
>> it's because people have already been
integrated into these spaces. These
communities are
>> Oh, what a what the what better way to
infiltrate a space than to turn the
people that are already there.
>> True.
>> I My view on Destiny changed. My view on
other creators did not.
>> Okay. So, you're a Loner Box fan?
>> Yeah. I like I watch his stream. Yeah, I
enjoy you participate. No, no negative
comments. No shenan
>> sometimes. I have negative comments, but
I haven't certainly Are you expressing
negative sentiment about streams you
watch? Um, excuse me. Are you expressing
negative sentiment about streamy watch,
man? Really
>> run any negative operations, you
wouldn't be a part towards him, right?
>> I What are you referring? Are you
referring to something?
>> Are you asking me to refer to something?
I'm just asking if you ever would ask.
If this if these are the crimes, when
are they going to start speaking out on
behalf of Child Logic? If these are the
crimes, when are they going to start
speaking out for the biggest victim,
Child Logic, and Dickers? If I've ever
been part of a uh operation to [__] with
Wick, go ahead, ask Dan, have you been
part of an operation to [__] with Wick?
>> No. Never. Not once. I don't even need I
don't even need you to ask me for an
example. I can say,
>> you know how when I ask you and you're
like, "What's which time?" Uh,
>> Dan, cuz you're coming to me trying to
menace me in DMs. It's really [__]
weird. And I just want to talk about
your car with the funky sideways speedo.
>> What you want to do is you want to paint
like
you are a
>> Are you going to paint lollies on the
side of your car? Dan,
>> an
internet terrorist. That's you. You are.
>> Then what are what are you?
>> So that's lit actual cope and
projection. Actual cop and projection.
Dan is literally doing the the careful
[__] right now. I'm a uh I guess you
could say like a little bit of like a a
vigilante of justice.
>> Insane. It's just like totally
corrosive.
>> Yeah.
>> I don't know. I think that's kind of
gay. You ever read the art?
>> You would know. Read the art.
>> Reading is gay. Like you say,
>> I can tell you don't read. You get AIS
to read and write for you, right?
>> Uh no, not not read. That would be silly
because then I'd have to still listen,
right? And then you're kind of
>> you got it to summarize it for you and
then you just read the summary of it. I
mean, are you not using AI in this
server and then using actual retards?
You're using AR AR actual retards to
work on your [__] So,
>> retards.
>> You like that? I'll let you use that one
if you want to.
>> Shane, do you take a lot of uh
clinazipan?
>> No.
>> No. Can I ask how much you take?
>> That's just
>> Why would I tell you what dosage of
anything I take?
>> Why did you tell me you were prescribed
it?
>> I said that I take it for sleeping. I've
been very open with my life. That's one
of the best.
>> Do you feel like it Do you feel like it
affects your inhibitions?
>> No.
>> But there he's right there. This guy,
right? There are actual retards in that.
It's the sweat shop, bro. It's the sweat
shop, you know?
>> No.
>> And one of the best parts is that you
can kind of see me over the last 15
years online. And uh as a result, the
lack of change,
>> especially like reduct everything. So,
it's kind of hard to follow.
>> Well, you know, that's why I've been on
video for 15 years as well. So, you
know.
>> Yeah. I saw that. You remember that old
picture of you with the truck that you
sent to Nicholas Dioro?
>> No,
>> I remember that picture. I think it's
really funny. I think it's kind of cute,
Dad. I think it's like
>> Do you think I'm like I don't even know
what you're talking about, but if you
think that I'm like embarrassed of
whatever it is, if I send it,
>> you said that you regretted sending it,
but that's okay. I'll stop I'll stop
talking about it, Dan. I don't want to
make you uncomfortable.
>> You can send whatever you want. And
that's one of the benefits of being a
guy like me and living your life. You
>> just can't carry it is that you can
carry whatever. Hold nothing back. Throw
it all out. Every [__] piece. But
that's not going to stop me from drip
dropping the [__] I have about you and
about other people.
>> I'm cringing, dude.
>> Not cringing so much that you're going
to release the server logs though,
right? Not that much. You You want to
know what I have?
>> I'm totally fine with
>> I'm totally fine with releasing the
server logs. I would like them to be
released.
>> You Hey, you should call from within.
>> Yeah, let's get it done.
>> I have done that. You take away I am
powerless. That's how you stop the
rapist. Here, I will offer this.
>> Oh, rap. Whoa. Whoa. Dan, we're not
allowed to call people rapists in this
server. Didn't you hear the role change?
>> Okay. Well, that's how you stop a
abuser. You let yourself
>> Dan. Dan. Dan. Whoa.
>> Okay.
>> Why are you making these accusations,
Dan? That's not okay.
>> You're trying to diffuse the subject.
>> I'm not going to lie. So far, this been
nothing but positive for viewership and
money. So, I I don't really know what
the rape is. You know,
>> you can turn on.
>> This is maximizing.
>> It's just like I guess the rape is
menacing chatters. The rape is making a
bunch of like random chatters like
scared about engaging. That's the rape.
Very great. Highly moral use of your
time. It's the
>> I don't know a lot of the names of these
debate tactics. I just kind of roll with
them as they go.
>> Yeah. Well, well, we we I went through
the snarker tactics. I don't know if you
saw the the show earlier, but we went
through all the snarker tactics that
they engage in and then this maximizing
>> the infiltration when they were already
integrated previously.
>> Anyway, uh Tiny,
>> do you have Tony Tiny?
>> I have Yeah, I was
>> one more question then we do got to let
you go cuz I want to talk to Dan for a
minute.
>> Thank you, Machico, for the $5 with the
Sheba training super. Appreciate.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> Uh sure. Well, I wanted to ask about the
food shops question. Sure. because uh
food shops is somebody who in the past
has described themselves as a small pea
pedophile. They've talked openly about
their lollyong consumption. So what I'm
going to do and what I told for a few
hours just real quick
>> what I told Hold on. What I told food
shops that I would do is because most of
the allegations against her came from
sources which I now view as less
credible. I will take a look at those
accusations. Again, I am not saying that
we're going to change our mind. I don't
know. But we will re-review it to see if
she can have the content role removed.
But I can't litigate that now. I don't
know. I'm going to leave that up to my
mod team. I think that's fair.
>> I do you mind if I leave? Just a final
note on that. Something
>> final. Go ahead.
>> Yeah. Hobbit follower came in and said
that the uh the previous caller guy, I
forget his name, but said that he was a
a Mr. Girl fan. Uh
>> yeah.
>> Are you talking about Kilo was the
moderator? Kilo the Giant, the former
moderator that said he was upset.
>> You're rambling, Jen.
>> People were calling him
>> that. Oh, I just want to make sure we're
talking about the same Mr. Girl person
cuz I'm talking about
>> No, we're talking about a different
person.
>> Moderator that's now a different person,
Jan. Thank you. Thank you.
>> Formerly the Giant that said you're
sorry. Sorry. I ran
his last
>> I'm going to let My bad. My bad. My bad.
>> You got to let him give his last. Go
ahead.
>> Thank you, Dan. Thank you very um so
that person was a Mr. girl fan. Food
shops was also a very big Mr. Girl fan.
And you may recall that Mr. Girls was on
sort of a public internet crusade where
he was trying to push the idea that
people should be where he was trying to
argue for the idea that people should
try to be empathetic to people who were
who had those proclivities.
>> I am well as part of food shops and as
part of food shops fandom of Mr. girl.
She started to imitate this in her
version of of I guess integrating this
uh this
>> great man for her lollipon consumption
to claim that her therapist told her to
consume lollikon which is not what
happened. Um
>> she also says oh while you're here she
also said your family deserves to be
swatted and I think that is a grotesque
thing for anybody to say I don't think
anybody should be swatted but um yeah
that's my last thought even Hitler.
>> Not even obviously not doing your
[__] morals.
>> I'll see you later.
>> Wait Tony Tony I just want to say that
you did [__] garbage. Also, shout out
to Spicy Chat and uh you know, try not
to
>> call. Okay, the phone call. Okay.
>> What What is that? He just left. Why
does he run? Why?
>> Oh, wait. We got this lost. Make sure
you get lost.
>> God damn it.
>> What? Okay, so Dan, what's up? What can
I help you? You wanted to come on stream
and you wanted to talk and so here we
are.
>> I was just watching No, I was watching
CompSlop and I was watching Tony get
[__] body and uh
>> I don't know. I just thought I'd come
in, that's all. Also, um Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I don't know. I don't know what to
say. Uh I will say, you know what's
really funny?
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Um, all right. Hold on. Just hold
on one second. Let me say the glazing.
Clear one thing before.
>> Yeah, because Okay, bug. You say it's
glazing. Say I'm a narcissist. I am. I
am. I am. But also, it's important
because it undercuts a lot of what was
saying earlier in the stream, doesn't
it?
>> Me two seconds. Hold on.
>> Oh, okay. Okay. We're We're getting
permission, gang. We are We are uh
phoning into command right now. Okay.
We're phoning into command. We're going
to get We're going to get the go-ahad,
the green light. We'll see.
>> Okay. What's really f Okay, so as you
know, like two weeks ago, some [__]
dude reached out to Lonerbox, I'm
assuming a Lonerbox fan with all of
these leaks.
>> Yes.
>> And Lonerbox
was like a [__] [__] [__] and
doesn't publish any of the stuff. So
then they go to Hutch and I think Hutch
publishes some of it about himself,
>> but they're like I think they [__]
hated Destiny. So Destiny gets it last
and then but we get the whole thing. and
we go through it and it's so funny. So,
the second that this all gets I guess
the second it all got publicized, they
must have gotten rid of like half the
[__] server or something cuz we got
kicked out.
>> But now they've opened up the server and
because people hate some of the people
in the server so much again
[__] in there right now watching
these [__] retards coordinate. It is
the funniest [__] [__] in the world.
>> I literally I looked at the server. I
think I heard this live. I looked at the
server when he said that. I don't think
I even saw anyone coordinate. actually
have no idea what he was referring to as
coordinating and people's giving Tony
[__] for doing badly. But yeah, the
point is it's opened up.
>> Okay. Oh [__] Um,
>> damn.
>> Wait, I feel like I have to say proof or
else they're going to not say it's a gay
op. Hold on.
>> What's your proof? Give it to me.
>> Hold on. Cuz I'm doing this on two
computers. Uh, frugals. Dan's going to
need to update the claw plan to deal
with this new update. I don't think so.
Homeboy, I think I'm doing all right.
Frugal's mad. Who? Wait, what else is
going on here? Hold on. Someone said
live Tony suicide. I guess I don't think
that means that Tony's doing so hot in
that call. What do you think real quick?
>> Oh no. Can you do it? Can you do it? Can
you scroll back to see what they thought
of?
>> But guys, it's it's a massive
coordinated machine to push false
narratives. When someone does badly,
they're all like, "Wow, you [__] that
up, didn't you? Make it make sense.
>> On you in your own Discord, my guy. This
would never happen other places, bro.
This is what I'm talking about. You guys
are such [__] scum [__] bro. That
people turn against you. Like, gh I
don't even know. You have no principles,
no morals. Like, that's the I mean,
that's my biggest issue with the server.
You know, when they they have the thing,
it was uh was this a Chappelle thing?
They say, "My biggest issue is the
hypocrisy." And he's like, "You sure
it's not the raping?" I'm going to say
here the biggest issue it's not the
raping, it's the hypocrisy. Okay? I
don't I don't like this server that
they're saying they're better than me.
You are not better than me. None of you
guys in here are better than me. You're
all worse than me.
>> So, okay, here's where it really comes
out. This is all it's about is just
dragging people down into the same mud
cuz Destiny and Dan engage in behavior
that's like totally off-putting to like
any onlooker.
>> Hey, because you lie about it. That's
it. Spicy chat in other places, at least
they somewhat hold to their [__]
principles. As I said before, I didn't
see [__] Chudlo Logic in there, okay?
He wasn't in there. And Queman when he
was in there told you guys to stop being
[__] [__] I see people like
[__] Tony in there actually doing
[__] gay ops, okay? So, that's all
I'm going to say right there. It's like
it's cringe as [__] That's all I'm
going to say for the logs. Okay.
>> You know, the thing is like a lot of
people there's even people in there that
talked a [__] ton. Um I think even them
some of them are like um spicy chatters
but like you didn't see like I'll I'll
shout out one thing that I shouldn't.
There was a guy um named Q that was in
there and people were doing [__] up
[__] and some of it got deleted and he
the whole time he didn't have to.
>> Well Timmy I know that these re like
none of these retards will ever listen
but you know it's good to have just the
explanation there for other people and
uh viewers show up for it. What can I
say? and he was saying, "You shouldn't
be doing this shit." And uh I respect
that. Like in a place where no one
[__] has to see anything, that's um
that's good behavior. And I I saw that
from a few people. And I think it's
important to call out some good behavior
when you see it because if you're just
going to be like everyone in there is
[__] evil, uh it's not going to
[__] work.
>> Well, that's why that's why I said that
like there are levels of culpability
here. Like I don't have beef with you if
you were just in the server and you
didn't participate in these kind of
activities and harassment and campaigns
and coordination.
>> Well, like like that's the whole thing
is like genuinely if you go through and
you've looked through it kind of like as
much as I've looked through it and it's
a lot like I haven't been able to go
through everything but like um if you
look through it there's like
>> I'm hearing that there's a huge trans
fire now. take a blind eye to it. And
then there's people that like genuinely
don't [__] say anything. Like Quimman
was in there, but he has like [__] 20
messages. He doesn't do [__] all. So
useless there as a content creator just
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa. Take it easy.
>> Other places watching other people's
[__] Same [__]
>> Uh but like then you look at [__]
Riyle Kitten House and [__] Jock and
the two of them are like non-stop
[__] jerking themsel. Like I here's
my big issue with those two [__]
retards. I don't give a [__] if you're a
critic of me or you're a critic of
someone else. The issue becomes when
you're not a critic anymore. You're a
[__] sabotur. Literally sabotaging
the [__] movie cameras uh and
auditioning for extras on the [__]
movie. Bro, that is not you. You got a
[__] problem, man. You are obsessed
with Destiny to a level that's not
healthy. Like every piece of content
that guy does, every single one is about
Destiny. And it's just like, bro, I
understand the guy, he's a [__]
deviant. Okay, I get that. But to
dedicate your life to it, that means
that you are a worst deviant. You're
[__] his cast offs, JTO. You got to
get your [__] together, mate. Move the
[__] on. Do something else with your
[__] life. Like, it's just
embarrassing. Like, I don't know what to
say. I don't know what to say. The dude
is like he's lost. And I I feel
>> I mean, you know, point just tell what
Jason's doing wrong. That's really what
what I'd want to say, you know? I
haven't seen that. I haven't seen I
don't think there's anything inherently
wrong with just talking about someone
with a bunch
>> that like he's torn so many people with
him and it makes me sad. But that said,
ironically, half the server I didn't see
any bad [__] Maybe more than half, but
the other, you know, the other portion
[__]
>> we'll see who gets. Insane wild [__]
That's it.
>> Um,
>> yeah. Well, thanks for
>> So, there's that and that, you know,
don't forget that Kilo unironically has
tens of thousands of messages in Mr.
girls discord where he laments that he
is called a pedophile. He was a
moderator for Mr. Girl. Like I don't
know what to say here. Like this is just
a very awkward situation for everyone
that associates with this guy moving
forward. I know that he's name changed
and whatnot, but it's like I do not know
what is going on here on that situation.
I don't know why a guy that is saying
>> yeah this is this is aren't both of
these guys also people that probably
have thousands of messages lamenting
being called a ped pedophile pedophile
online pedophile pedophile but don't
both these guys do that too
>> wants like total death of a person is
making a video on that guy and then
acting unbiased but I think that bad
things should um happen to bad people
>> okay okay damn
>> on wait I don't mean like in real life I
just mean like bad things like
reputationally Right?
Daniel Saltman right here. That's me
right now. Okay? And I love people that
actually stick to their morals even when
it [__] hurts. Okay?
>> Okay. And there's a lot of them. There's
a lot of those people that would um, you
know, not want to stick to those [__]
morals. And
>> they dislike you. They dislike me, but
they don't they don't cross the [__]
line. And I don't cross the line with
them either. People paint me as some
insane [__] psychopath that's done
all this [__] nuts [__] And they
point to one instance from [__] 3
years ago with Hassan Piker's [__]
moderator that was calling me a [__]
pedophile uh and contacting people in my
life and sending them [__] And I don't
regret it. I'd [__] do it again on
that. But that said,
>> okay, but people literally aren't
engaging tactics any like for the most
part, people aren't engaging tactics any
worse than what he does to Hassan like
daily. like the most of its character.
Most of the character of the things
being done are like posting tweets,
posting clips, you know, and even
there's a pretty hard standard.
Obviously, I'm sure there's stuff that
gets posted that isn't like this.
There's a pretty hard standard for
telling the truth as well, which Dan
doesn't seem to have.
>> That's the one thing that they [__]
have as far as like reaching out to
someone when they've done insane [__]
Hey, that's a standard that's being set
by other people now on that front. Um,
but that said, the hustle, etc.
Everything else, I think we're I think
we're good. Also, hold on. Let me just
double check one thing real quick here.
Hold on. Uh, we're not getting any new
messages coming in from Dan bragging
about having moles in here. It's over.
And then no more chats after
>> bad.
>> Teeny tiny Tony.
>> Your debate [__] sucks. Zero of 10.
>> Not even transcribing for Snarky. Okay.
>> All right. Well,
>> thanks for thanks for coming in and
we'll have you on more and uh we'll talk
more and I'm I'm eager to see what comes
all this. Okay, man.
>> Yep.
>> We'll talk to you then.
>> Okay.
>> Bye.
>> Goodbye, friends.
>> Oh, boy. Oh, boy. Oh, boy.
>> Well, that was uh that was great stuff.